Big suck my to all the Israel fighters out there. You rabbid
ultra Zionist pigs. You run around going, "Oh my god, Israel
first. Israel first. Why are you tying this back to Palestine?"
He did the voice. The voice is so good. Why are you tying this
back to Palestine? >> Hey, give me Tik Tok. Work for Israel.
Give me CBS. Work for Israel. Give me the American government.
[music]
Hello. Hello. Hello.
How's it going, guys?
How we doing
How we doing? How are we feeling? How's it going? What's up?
What's up? What's up? It's Friday, January 30th. We're back.
You know what's funny?
Nick Fentes and and Hassan fighting each other on Twitter. That
was funny. That was like a little goofy thing. I I threw this
up. Okay.
No, not my not my two favorite streamers. No, no,
no.
It old fight from yesterday, right? Where Hassan basically had
his clip where he got banned. Okay.
And Nick says it's censorship, not just Israel, but you'll never
go there. Which I thought was funny. Okay. Because
essentially Nick was like fighting against this Israel comparison
that Hassan was doing. Didn't like it.
Right.
The son responds, "I won't go there because I'm not a [__]
and it's not about Judaism no matter how hard you, Jonathan Greenblat,
and Mark Levvin all claim it's tied. Get your booger eating by
curious Mexican ass out of here and go sell some more Epstein
hoodies, little man." Wow.
And this responds, "Yeah, bro. The state of Israel, the ADL,
project of Benth
and their billionaire benefactors have nothing to do with LMFAO.
You say that supporting ICE is Zionist, but mass migration is
the most policy of all time and you are a collaborator.
Okay, dude. The little man comment was out of pocket.
Uh, it is out of pocket a little bit. Okay. Jeez,
what the hell did he do to you, man? Except, you know, stand
against everything you stand for.
You think are monolithic because you are simple-minded. You believe
in tribe. I
this isn't true, but imagine Hassan speaking to like one of Nick's
followers. It It applies perfectly.
You believe in tribalism. I recognize class. You ferment emnity
against entire subgroups and divide the working class because
you're a slave to Trump and billionaires that all defend Israel
because of their investments.
That was a little wobbly. Defend Israel because of their investments
in Israel.
Okay. Um
but I I don't mind this this reading. This is how they'll see
each other. I didn't vote for Trump, dumbass. You're not working
class. You're a millionaire live streamer getting paid by Amazon.
And they don't defend Israel because of their investments. They
are they are captured by the Israel lobby, which is motivated
by messianic fanatical race loyalty.
Um, Hassan is talking.
Nick is not talking as well. Nick is Nick's really good at talking
[__] to right-wingers. I don't think he knows very
much about
at all.
So, he's not very good at talking to Hassan. Hassan knows a little
bit about him.
Right. Like Nick Nick mostly attacks right-wingers from the right.
I would say Hassan spends it's it's kind of funny that Hassan
gets compared a lot by like liberals to Nick Fuentes because
he does attack the left from the left. He attacks Democrats from
the left. But Nick basically doesn't attack people like Hassan
at all. Right. He focuses almost entirely on the right wing.
He's almost entirely internal critique.
And it's funny because people will compare them in that way,
but Hassan is clearly more interested or knows more about Nick
and can talk. It's kind of funny.
Kind of funny. Kind of funny.
Okay, so the son responds, "I'd rather be a class trader traitor
than a gay Mexican manlet."
And Dev responds, "You are two you two are more aligned with
each other than with liberals." Dude, Dev had a tweet trying
to call Hosano for a debate. And I'm like, bro, you ducking me,
dog. You ducking me.
How are you calling Hano? You ducking me. Where's this tweet?
Sweet guy. Oh, he's a reply. That's why. He's calling Hano for
a debate. I'm like, bro, you're ducking me all the time. I've
asked you for a debate multiple times.
And you're like the guy who's all about open ideas. We We just
compare our ideas. We argue, man. We just argue, man.
We got that one. You Nick responds, "You're a barely literate
to Turk roach that abuses animals." Oh my god, he's getting racist.
He's getting racist.
And I don't know if Assan responds to this, actually. Does he
respond to it?
Assan's been responding to a lot of stuff recently. Looks like
he doesn't respond to this one, unless it's this clip from his
stream that Substances just sent me. Is this the clip? Turns
for prominent anti-semite, avowed white supremacist, prominent
anti-semite Nicholas Fuentes,
there is one group of people that he hates more than what is.
Let's take a look at who that group is.
No, there isn't. What? No, there isn't.
No, there there can't possibly be. What?
That doesn't drive with anything I know about Nick. >> Twitch,
which uh W's in the chat. Hassan [__] just got banned.
>> By the way,
I'll say I don't think Nick has any actual true problem with
Hassan.
I actually don't. I don't think he has any real like true problem
with Hassan. I think it's all performance cuz he knows that like
he's really transgressive in a lot of ways and he can do that.
But you can't be transgressive on the Hassan issue on the right.
You can't say like, "Oh, Hassan's cool." Actually, you can't
do that. You can't get away with that. I actually think in terms
of like aesthetics,
Fuente uh Fuentes aligns with Hassan would like Hassan in like
every way. Nick is like very aesthetically based and he would
like Hassan if Hassan had any chance of liking Nick.
I believe that he would actually go and
I I believe that Nick would go or sorry, Nick would go and like
like Hassan. He would be cool with Hassan. But I think he knows
Hassan will never ever ever give him anything. And so he does
this. >> Hassan [__] just got banned on Twitch
for calling supporters of ICE Zionist
He says if you support ICE, you're a Zionist pig.
Really?
Once again, it's like what is the value of someone like that?
Assan the >> I know they stack that high. Assan Oh,
height reference too. Why you bringing up height, baby?
That's just odd.
It's just odd to bring up height like that. I didn't know they
stack
that
>> Has his son never seen Full Metal Jacket?
Has he just never watched that movie?
Yeah. Has he never I guess he's just never seen that movie. who
should
>> it would have been so [laughter]
if he could have just responded to Nick that he's just not much
he doesn't look like a sear to him. Okay, that would have been
he would have won completely. Well, you don't look like a sear
to me. >> Reported back to Turkey. >> Come on, DUDE.
>> HONESTLY, WE SHOULD JUST put him in the ocean like Osama
bin Laden. >> We should just give him a watery grave like
Bin Laden. Just tie weights to his ankles and throw him overboard.
I don't care who the does it. I don't care if the IDF does it.
Hey Netanyahu, if you can hear us, can you do us a solid?
Netanyahu, if you're listening, you know what would would do
you know what would get all of Jenz white guys?
That makes that makes Hassan's entire audience super psyched.
Okay. Hassan's entire audience right there when he does that,
they're like Nick Fuentes is like an Israeli agent.
>> Right-wingers to support Israel again. You need to go
Maduro on Hassan [__] and throw him in the ocean.
Give him a watery grave. You want us to support Israel? You want
to make the case? Why should we ally with Israel? You know, that
would be a start.
This is I mean, we this is not surprising I hope to anybody really
that's been paying attention,
but he's out here eating Israel,
dude. Hassan, [clears throat] why is everybody trying to get
Hassan?
Like I I do get how people are annoyed with the guy generally.
Why is everybody trying to get this guy? Why is everybody like
this guy should die probably? Hey everyone. Everyone Hassan should
probably This is a joke by the way. I'm imitating them. I'm calling
it out. Okay, just to be clear in case there's an algorithm listening.
This is a joke. But like it's just like, oh, Hassan, wouldn't
it be better if Hassan was dead? There's so many people who are
just saying this over and over again. Bro, can you guys chill?
You guys all chill?
Nick handed him a free W. Well, Nick wasn't funny there. Nick
was actually That was It was weird. He just He couldn't. Like
I said,
that's how maybe this is the best indication that Nick is actually
gay is because he actually can't get angry at an attractive man.
He can't do it. He can't summon the energy to be truly upset
with Assan. And so, he can't really even be funny or anything.
He has to like force
He's just like he like sees he he talks about his he like pictures
his face and he's like
I didn't know they stacked that high man. I maybe Netanyahu should
get you. Maybe Netanyahu should maybe Netanyahu should get you
right now. It's like okay all right. He's usually pretty good
at talking out of nowhere. It's like not He just totally fumbles.
He just totally like what happened? Where where' that falloff
come from? with the hopes that Israel will [__]
you know,
>> Israel Netanyahu should like black tag you and like
bring you to Chicago or
Totally. Totally. That should happen. Sorry.
Okay. All right.
Weird weird segment. Weird segment. Maybe we go to the Hassan
ban stuff right away.
Do we go to that right away? Yeah.
All right. We're going to go look at the original clip that got
him banned. All right.
We're going to look at this thread. We're going to look at the
cause, all of this, and then we'll go into his stream from today
and how he's staying winning. Okay. Despite the man can't keep
him down.
I basically saw this clip from Dan. This is a clip from a Dan
post. I took his clip. I >> This is another big suck my
to all the Israel writers out there. You rabbid ultra Zionist
pigs. You run around going, "Oh my god, Israel first. Israel
first." Why are you tying this back to Palestine?
[laughter] He did the voice. The voice is so good. Why are you
tying this back to
Israel first. Israel. Why are you tying this back to Palestine?
>> You rabbit ultra Zionist pigs. You rabbit ultrainist
pigs. You rabbit ultrainist pigs. This is another big suck my
dick to all the Israel. Oh, that's just looped right there. Okay,
so that's 20 seconds I posted that
was denying that Hassan was doing a Jew voice. Um, well, isn't
that also is that not also his Iranian voice that he did?
I'm trying to think of the
the Iranians on the beach voice that he did. I think it's the
same voice as >> This is another big suck my
Israel. >> Let's listen
one more time. You [__] rabbit ultra zinist pigs.
You run around going, "Oh my god, Israel first. Israel first."
Why are you tying this back to Palestine?
It's the same voice.
I can't tell if it's a it's a serious voice. Anyway,
so this is from Dan. Here's Dan explaining why he thinks to violation.
It's Dan's clip. And then it is basically let's see here.
Ribbit uh
similar to other terms that may be used as a proxy for protected
groups as a proxy for Israelis. If the word is used to promote
uh in in a context to promote harm or violence or when used to
make dehumanizing comparisons or perpetuate anti-semitic stereotypes,
Zionist name of animal. Yeah. Like I I just think
like Hassan's making a point here and I I made this argument
at the time when they proposed doing this when they were like
trying to say this and I'm like dude when he says pigs like he's
doing the fascist thing. He's saying they're like Zionist, fascist,
authoritarian,
yeah, like gross in that way. Like it's pretty clear what he
means. Didn't think that should be an example. Now it's an
Very goofy.
So from here for the with regards to the Hassan ban, Hassan responded
to my post. Where's the first post that Hassan responded to?
So here's the full context in the Hassan thing. He uh he responded
here. 16,000 likes on this response. It's also zoomed in to show
to not show what I was reading, which is an article about DHS
domestic terrorist surveillance lists on pro Palestine/ anti
activists.
So, let's go watch the full context here real quick.
All right, this is the full context from the Austin Postil
outfit to
back it up. >> The man in our footage is wearing a similar
outfit to what Prey was wearing on the day he was. >> What
appears to be a gun is also visible above his waistband.
What's more likely is that they filmed his face and they put
him on a watch list as Ken Clippenstein reports in his exclusive
Sparta Reaper and Grapevine tracked protesters and their friends
plus others. ISIS secret watch list of Americans. We have a nice
little database and now you're considered domestic terrorism.
Mass federal agent taunted a protester filming him in Maine last
week. If you recall, remember this video. We've covered videos
like this on
>> is this the um
generated by Sparta. Is Sparta the application that um Palanteer
made >> numerous occasions on this broadcast where ICE
agents will walk up to counterprotesters will walk up to pro
protesters and film them in their faces and go smile. You're
on camera. You're on a watch list now. Department of Homeland
Security spokesperson Trisha Mccclaclin's response was firm.
There is no database of domestic terrorists run by ICE. There's
just one problem. She's
Sparta Science joins Palunteers FedStart to accelerate access
to AI enabled human readiness technology for US government
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. So cool. >> Two-seater national
security officials tell me that there are more >> Oh, actually,
it's funny, Maximus. I just I just found that same thing.
Yeah, I just looked at that. I just looked this up as well. Jesus.
>> More than a dozen secret and obscure watch list that
Homeland Security and the FBI are using to track protesters,
both anti-ICE and pro Palestinian. This is another big suck my
dick to all the Israel dick writers out there. You [__]
rabid ultraionist pigs. You run around going, "Oh my god, Israel
first, Israel first. Why are you tying this back to Palestine?"
Because this is precisely the same [__]
Um, wait. DZ,
you say I can't sweep for Hassan. I literally said this rule
was
I said this was absolutely stupid. He's not doing something racist
when he says what he says. You could say you just want Hassan
banned. That's fine, right? Like if they put in a rule that just
said like black people can't be on Twitch and then you cam up
and you're black, you get banned. I would still say that's wrong.
Even like I would be against the rule. I'm against this rule.
You could say, "Oh, you can't sweep for." Well, I'm not saying
he couldn't get banned under the toss. I'm saying that the toss
rule that they added for the ADL is
it's completely It's like the dumbest thing I've ever seen.
It's always been.
And I think Hassan stood on business here. And because he stood
on business, he was massively rewarded,
>> right?
Which we'll get into after this, but he was massively rewarded
today. You Israel first monsters, dude. Jesus Christ. How can
you say that? When the first when the first immigration action
that the Trump administration took was literally try to deport
uh anti-Israel protesters, trying to deport people for writing
articles in their student newspaper against Israel, hurting
like it's he's just totally correct on the politics here. like
totally completely correct on the politics here,
right?
Like he is he should he is angry for the exact right reason.
Israel like Israel has influence in the US government that especially
over the Trump government. Okay, Zion Don is second to none.
And he's correct that they tried to deport they tried to denaturalize
and not denaturalize they tried to deport green card holders
who were doing like anti-Israel protests in the US. Right. >> you
went to >> uh division five player. Thank you very much
for the tier one sub. Appreciate it, man.
And
well, I'm just watching the clip. I'm saying the rule is stupid.
I'm not going to say the same thing. I'm just going to watch
the clip
anyway. I think the rule is stupid.
So, and he's pointing out that that it's obviously like Israel
first, American politicians who are putting forth this kind of
policy who keep advancing this and it's cutting down civil liberties
for all Americans.
>> Israel's feelings. And then they still act like this
is not the identical situation.
It's a conspiracy. It's a conspiracy that that uh one of the
biggest pro-Israel IDF donors went and [__] purchased
Tik Tok specifically because he wanted to make it pro Israel
and that every single person that played a role.
>> I got to I got to do it to him. I got to hit him. I
got to hit him with it one more time, guys. >> Then you
do this >> one more time. One more time. >> Okay.
I didn't do the meme. I didn't do the meme. I'm just saying this.
Okay. This is the Larry Ellison. Hey, give me Tik Tok. Work for
Israel. Give me CBS. Work for Israel. Give me the American
>> Dude, it's like
it's like oh my god. Chank Chank is like so performatively anti-racist
that he is like not that he like can't even do this correctly
that he's like barely touching the line. And then like a demon
an anti-semitic demon possesses him and he just starts doing
a >> This is the Larry Ellison. Hey, give me Tik Tok. Work
for Israel. Give me CBS. Work for Israel. Give me the American
>> You can hear the tone shift when the demon takes over.
It's like right there. He's just talking totally normally. >> I'm
just
>> I'm just I'm not doing the meme. I'm not doing anything
racist, guys.
>> This is the Larry Ellison.
>> here it is. Give me T.
work for Israel.
Give me CBS.
Work for Israel.
Give me the American
>> Dude, he's just a It's a crazy clip, man. That's a crazy
clip.
You see Chen went on Tucker. >> Politician that played
a role in the sale of Tik Tok openly said they were selling Tik
Tok because they were scared that people were becoming too Israel.
Every single person that refuses to acknowledge that, that tries
to disparage, that tries to [__] disparrage people
for calling this out, that tries to deflect attention away from
this issue, is a monstrous liar that is only invested in Israel
and nothing else.
Dude, I think this is like Hassan picked the perfect way to get
banned. I wouldn't be shocked if he like had if there was forethought
that went into this. Like he's totally correct. He's drawing
attention to an issue in like a major way.
He's winning in like every possible way on this. It's shocking.
I've I've never seen a Hassan win like this where he's like totally
correct on the politics. He's totally correct on the message
he's sending. His ban draws attention to the message he's sending,
right? Like I wouldn't shock me if he used this intentionally.
He was like, "Yeah, get me banned for this. Go ahead. Try to
get me banned for this. See what happens. See what happens."
Now, if I remember correctly,
was it secular talk was one of the first ones in defending Hassan?
Wait, hold on. Secular
talk.
Wait, what is Kyle
Kyle Kolinsky
Hassan?
Yes, Kyle Kolinsky the Hassan. Kyle Kolinsky tweet #freehassan.
Holy,
this is such an embarrassment. at Twitch at Twitch support. Why
the should anybody stream on Twitch when they apparently will
ban people for telling the truth? Oh my god.
Uh his claim the ICE violation is tied to Israel is at least
speculation with with uh not outright disinformation. He has
no proof of that. Wait, he's saying
hold on. That wasn't the claim. That was a comparison. Wait,
did he did he say that the ICE violence is because of Israel?
I thought it was just a
Wait, what? What are we doing where he show me where he said
the ICE violence is because of Israel? Israel wants ICE violence.
What he said was the same AI they used to track um anti-CE protesters,
they used to track anti-Israel protesters, pro Palestine
For me, it's implied. Where? How is it implied? Give me Give
me the example of where it's implied when he makes a comparison.
That's
X is like Y. Oh, you're saying X is because of Y? No, that's
not how that works. That's not how a comparison works. What?
Sorry. I think Desperate Worm's talking about something else.
I think Desperate Worm's talking about when he did the original
thing where he's talking about how this was like the like the
IDF,
right? He's talking about them in this case, he's talking about
them using some Palunteer funded AI setup that's being used to
track both anti-Israel protesters, pro Palestine protesters,
and anti-ICE protesters. But that's
That's that's true. But that's not saying that the ICE violence
is because of Israel. That's not the same thing.
And that's a fact is a little different.
Anyway, wow. Cool. So, moving on from that, I'm looking for other
other reactions. We got the Aiden Ross reaction. Do we get an
Asmin Gold reaction, guys?
Do we have any Asmin Gold reaction to [__] being
banned? We've got to We've got to, right?
>> WHERE THEY AT? >> NO WAY. >> YES. [screaming]
OH MY GOD. OH. Cuff him. Cuff him. Oh my
>> Oh my god. I know. I'm going to look. Oh my god. Stop.
Watch. >> Cuff him. There is no way. Cuff him. I'm going
to celebrate. No. >> The streamer ban
might be IN HIS CH. >> YES. [screaming]
>> IS THAT REAL? >> YOU DOG ABUSER. YOU HATE AMERICA.
YOU [laughter]
>> MOVE TO CHINA.
HOLD ON. WE got to FACT CHECK THIS. FACT CHECK. Streamer
bands. HOLD ON, CHAT. FAT CHECK. HOLD ON. HOLD ON.
>> I'M SMOKING ON HASSAN. >> WE BANG IT. We
[gasps] lol.
>> we did get him. We did get him.
>> Okay, that's just funny. I'm sorry. That is really funny
to me. >> I'm smoking on you. You [laughter] suck. I always
knew there was something weird about you, bro. Stop abusing Ka
and this wouldn't happen. >> I guess Peter officially stepped
in.
>> It's I think it's just I think it's hilarious that Aiden
went with the Havillo. Okay, right off the bat. This is good
times, man. This is great times. Uh Asmin commented in two places.
Hold on. Let's see here.
Which terms of service update?
>> Hold on. >> People that do the opposite, too.
But at the same time, if you go and you watch Hassan reading
the manifesto of the shooter that two uh Israeli diplomats, these
are random young people that were a couple and he just straight
up gunned them down and killed them. Those two people, and you
read his chat, they're reading his manifesto and his chat in
sub only emote mode. I don't know if it was sub only, but
I There's no way Asminold's going to advocate. How can Asminold
advocate for looking at the chat,
Bro, why
are spamming the heart of his own community sub badge?
>> That's his own ones. Those are people that are subs.
That is his community. These are not bad actors. These are people
that are part of your Dude, how
can the Rip Bozo guy say that? Dude,
how can the Rip Bozo guy say this?
That's crazy. That's wild stuff, right?
Renee Good gets shot. Rip Bozo. Rip Bozo. Packwatch on Renee
Good. If just gone packwatch on these protesters, shouldn't have
supported. Shouldn't have worked for a genocidal government in
a state that supports them. Shouldn't have done that. if he'd
done that, which by the way, I do think that there's probably
people uh either who are adjacent to Assan or adjacent of adjacent
of Assan who would make that argument. I know Noah Samson essentially
made that argument. Okay, he might not like it, but Noah Samson
100% made that argument that if you're like a diplomat for Israel,
if you're somebody in the US, that that's people you should target,
which is super sketchy. I don't like that, right? But they would
stand on that in political belief that those people are committing
violence through their actions by supporting a genocidal
Right? Like there's an argument there. If you want to say, well,
if I have an argument for why this is a justified murder, then
I can support it all all I like on stream,
which is I assume as argument when he supports the Renee Good
shooting, right?
Well, then I I think there is an argument on the other side doing
this whenever you're reading a M. >> By the way, I don't
agree with those arguments. I totally disavow political violence.
I think it usually works against your movement completely. But
I'm saying that Asmin Gold doesn't Asmin Gold is willing to support
violence, right, in certain cases.
And Hassan's community is I think Hassan called it out. Hassan
said the guy was articulate, which was I suppose you can of somebody
who murdered two people and they're justifying it and you're
spamming hearts. You shouldn't be surprised when you get the
word Zionist
>> Really? Like I mean, that's just the
the Zionist ban, the the actual toos ban came way before that
as well.
The the actual the ban he's referring to the toos update came
way before the the dipl the the diplomat shooting at the museum
at the Holocaust Museum or whatever.
Very strange.
I I think I'm like one of the only streamers with timeline perception.
I'm the only person who like organizes things temporally in my
brain. It's very lucky. Very, very cool. Very lucky.
Oh, we had a POS reaction. Oh, the guy who Hassan broke. This
guy reacted too. Do you guys remember this guy?
>> It sucks cuz man, I don't I don't even want to support
Hassan.
I really don't. I really don't cuz it's just it's bad optics,
man. Supporting Hassan. I I swear it's just bad optics. But for
me, I can look at this and I totally opposed that ADL rule update.
I said it was stupid at the time. I hated it. Right.
And then he got banned on calling out Israel, like justifiably
calling out Israel, the US government, justifiably spitting facts,
and he got banned for it because he's bad at.
And I just I think he I just totally agree with him.
Totally agree with him in this case. >> What's good, chat?
What's good, chat? You know what the funniest part is, bro? >> You
know what the funniest part is?
>> Um,
all I All someone said to me, literally I got I literally I got
a DM,
the terrorist is banned.
Immediately I knew what they were talking about.
which is the sound is
>> the son is banned. Guys, did you hear
>> That's what people call him, but
um yeah, I don't know. But I mean, he he'll be unbanned.
>> What's good, Chad? >> Oh, hold on. Had actually
responded to this one. Give me a sec, kid. The clip I'm about
to show you
is another peer of mine. This is another content creator in this
space. Think about how [__] racist this [__]
is. >> This was his reaction to me getting banned last
night. >> Literally, I got a DM.
>> The terrorist is banned.
Immediately I knew what they were talking about, which is the
sad part.
>> is Hassan. Wait.
Oh, now now I can finally dig into this guy. Oh, thank you for
saying something stupid.
Hold on. Racist.
Do you think people are calling you a terrorist because you're
Arab? Because you're Well, you're not Arab, you're Turkish.
Like that? That's different. But um because you're Muslim. Do
you think they're calling you terrorist because you're Muslim?
That's not why that's not why they're calling him a terrorist.
They're calling him a terrorist because he outright supports
certain terrorist groups that he thinks are resisting Israel.
groups that have been designated terrorist groups.
There are arguments, by the way.
Uh, okay. I don't care. There are arguments, by the way, that
he has for why it's like specifically he'll support those groups
that he doesn't see them as terrorist groups for certain reasons,
right? And that's a whole thing you could talk about, right?
So, I I don't think it's like as easy as, oh, he supports terrorist
groups, therefore he should be banned for like supporting those
groups or something, which a lot of people do. But I I think
it's pretty obvious that that's why everybody calls him a terrorist
because he supports groups that are designated terrorist groups
like pretty obviously. >> That's what people call him.
But >> there should be an environment of shame.
There should be at least a little bit of social stigma
calling a a
Muslim
pro Palestinian Twitch streamer a if Assan was Arab,
I would probably agree here because he's not Arab because he's
clearly like white. He's a white Turk. Okay, I don't agree. I
don't agree with the racism part. You could say it's um Islamophobia.
Maybe it's not racist. terrorist like this just rolls off the
tongue. A lot of people don't understand that if you are in any
way, shape, or form pro Palestine, especially if you're Arab,
I'm not Arab, I'm Turkish, or Muslim, you >> Yeah. Okay.
Okay. Yeah. Sure. If he was Arab, I would probably agree on the
racism thing because it's just like a super easy connection.
>> Constantly eating this and you're expected to eat this
on a daily basis. Have some shame, man. the clip I'm about to
I think he's been painted as a terrorist with like justifiable
reasons to do so in the same way that people call techto right
and it's like oh you're just you know you're you're being like
prejudice against Neander Neanderthal looking it's like no there's
like some credible reason to call you a actually that's why people
do it not because not because you look like a Neanderthal who
that's not why techone it's because there's some credible reasons
there's some actual reasons people have laid out the arguments
and they believe them. That's why to >> show you.
>> Anyway,
disagree on the racist part.
But I think I mean it's prejuditial. Sure. Could be Islamophobic.
You could consider it as Islamophobic. I think it just tends
to be the fact that there's millions of views on videos laying
out the reasons you could call Hassan a terrorist or terrorist
sympathizer, terrorist supporter, and that most people agree
with those reasons.
Are we going to the loner box reaction now? Dude, the loner box
reaction was um I thought it was a little it's a little funny
people handring about it after Hassanabi surpasses 115,000
live viewers. Wait, what? I thought he was banned on YouTube.
Oh,
British B British Loerbox reacts with a public meltdown that
includes endorsement of self harm rhetoric.
I just think you're a goof if you if you if you truly believe
this. I think this is weird to be like disingenuous to go after
people, right? I suspect that the person here doesn't really
actually have a moral objection to self harm rhetoric. Okay,
just saying. I suspect
Yeah, it's
I suspect. Anyway, this was streamed on his YouTube channel.
Yeah, I think this is like borderline fed posting. I think it's
pretty gay to do. Personally, I think it's pretty gay. Like pretty
obviously gay, by the way. like the same state that literally
uses allegations of terrorism to persecute Kurds. God, you are
such a man.
>> But like I will say
you start to get into dicey situations when you are supporting
movements to get like this guy's favorite streamer is probably
Hassan, right? If you're supporting movements to get Hassan banned,
then you're going to have individual people who come out and
try to get the same thing to happen to you, right? And realistically,
I think there's a whole bunch of people who support this Hassan
ban based on the fact that it's like a tickytacky toos thing.
Even though Hassan was telling the truth, even though Hassan
was in the right with everything he said, even though that's
the case, people are like, "Well, it's the toos and that that
you got to follow the toos."
So, it's a little hard to get too angry if people aren't going
to call that out. I call it out. I'll call out both. But, I'm
like the only person who's like, "Hey, maybe we shouldn't try
to get each other banned. Maybe we shouldn't have like rules
in the US that prevent you from speaking freely.
But apparently that's like unique nowadays. Crazy. >> That's
what people call them. But um >> they call you that because
you support terrorists. That's why. Well, you think it's cuz
you're Turkish. Get over yourself, man. You're a white American
who supports terrorists. So they call you a terrorist.
>> I can see I can see why a lot of people dislike my opinion.
Seems to align a little bit with loner boxes. >> I don't
know. But I mean, he'll be
>> within uh I mean who knows
>> like there should be an environment of shame. There
should be at least a little bit of social stigma.
>> Calling a a Muslim >> pro Palestinian Twitch streamer
a
This is exactly what I've had to do for the past two years. Now
many of these guys have to turn around >> disavow. We'd
never we'd never endorse self harm rhetoric on this stream. Okay.
We would never do that. That would be >> I love free Palestine,
bro. I don't [__] with that kind of stuff at He must
know how dishonest or like full of [__] he is. Like
how do people listen to that? >> almost 3 years now >> a
Muslim prop. [__] off. >> Every single prop
Turkish person by the
I I mean I think it's a little virtue signaly as well. I don't
think Hassan really thinks POS is racist towards him. I think
Hassan doesn't like racism that Arabs see in the same vein. And
I would say that some people will call Arabs,
you know, terrorists. They'll call Arabs terrorists and they'll
say, you know, supporting Hamas or being pro Palestine, that's
supporting Hamas, that's proter terrorism. That gets you deported.
I he around the margins. I see why Hassan would make this argument,
why he'd like lay it out for people. I don't think he truly believes
it applies to him, but it's probably to him like a useful case
that he can point out.
I just noticed how fast his chat is moving, though. Apparently,
Hassan popped the off today, by the way.
So, we're going to go to that in just a second. But I do want
to keep watching, guys. Do we have any more Packwatch clips,
tweets? I wanted So, I I know Dan brought this up on anything
else. I asked for it. I didn't see if anybody found it. Let me
go check the Discord really quickly cuz I know Dan was talking
about it on anything else cuz I got linked some uh some conversations
about it.
Oh, hold on. Right here. Apparently, this is around where we
go.
Let's see. Let's see. Let's see. >> True.
I don't like that guy at all. Honestly, I'm starting to think
that he's actually not
a friend of the
>> Do you think you were the reason you got he got banned?
>> Uh, if I had I think I take some part in
>> That is absolutely the reason or >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I I lifted the thing from the H3 H3 Productions website
the the video. I just reposted it. >> But, uh, any credit
I can take, I mean, I think he's mad. I saw him crashing out
in Jtock's comments, which is a good >> What do you mean
JTock's comments? >> I mean, Hassan [__] responded
to JTock
on Twitter.
>> About this ban.
>> What did JTock say?
>> Jtock was like, "Dan Saltman did this." That crack.
>> Wait, but Dan Saltman did do this. I My tweet was so
based. You have no idea how awesome my tweet is, okay? because
there's no way anybody can accuse me of being remotely biased
here.
This is the clip that led to Hassan the Hun getting banned. It
seems like attention was brought to it by Dan K stream yesterday.
Here's the post from Dan explaining why he believes this is a
toss violation. Yeah, how do you even get mad at me for this?
This is just true.
Here's the full context for the comments. And I post the other
Hassan clip right here.
This is obviously true, man. What are we
And then Hassan was like, >> "Oh, hold on. Little little
JN going on here." Little JN. >> What did JTock say? >> JTO
was like, "Dan Saltman did this. That crafty." And then Hassan
was like, "I can't believe it." Or some, you know, I'm I'm a
bridging this a little bit.
>> Wait, what did Hassan say? I think Hassan just said,
what did he say specifically? He said it's also zoomed in to
not show what I was reading, which is an article about DHS domestic
surveillance or surveillance list on pro Palestine/ anti activist.
The Ken Clippenstein article we now see, right,
which is true. I don't know if that's crashing out. That's like
providing
that crashing out.
Where's a crash out?
Do you think Hassan's going to stop being mean to the now?
>> Do you think he's going to double down?
>> Uh,
last night I think Fuentes responded to him and he was like,
"Oh, what did he say?" He said something along the Oh, hold on.
[laughter] Look at this. I want to be crystal clear. I've never
once called for banning of the word Zionist. There's absolutely
to criticize inside the Zionist movement. I've only called for
DJ Clansancy to step down. I do not want this new rule. It's
oh boy. It's Wait, Hassan broke the rule. Get him out of here.
Hassan broke the rule.
Dan Clancy at ADL, guys. He broke the rule. He broke the rule,
guys. He broke the rule.
He totally broke He broke it. He broke the rule.
Very funny.
very very very funny. All right. I by the way when I originally
wrote this I wrote some crazy in here just to annoy people and
then I'm like you know what I'm going to I'm going to actually
double back and I'm just going to make this like I'm just going
to make it factual. I'm going to make it non-biased. I'm just
going to say what happened. The original tweet was like looks
like the collaboration between Ethan Klein, Dan Saltman, and
the IDL finally paid off. That was like the original tweet with
this clip.
>> That was I was going to go way harder. I was going to
say what Dan actually said. Okay. So, maybe he sensed it. Maybe
he used his his telepathy to sense that that was the direction
I was leaning and he called me out knowing that there was that
was the direction I was leaning. Okay.
But um but I didn't tweet that. >> Actually, I can just
read it verbatim if I can find it. Um,
he said it, Fuentes said to Hassan, "It's censorship, not just
Israel, but you'll never go there." >> I saw that. >> And
and I was going to do the whole like
Lord of the Rings, like
I I could do that meme with Hassan, the sooner Hassan just becomes
full.
>> Oh, I see what you're saying here, Kathy. Um, I don't
know about this.
Twitch updated their hateful conduct policy because of me. Ethan
didn't like that people were saying he was collaborating with
the ADL,
right? So, he changed the title, which says Zionist is now a
slur.
He didn't like the um he didn't like how the original title was
painting him, so he changed it.
interesting, interesting. We've apparently got some logs from
Dan about the stream today. Let's keep listening for a second.
move on to someone else that matters and have them not being
so the problem with Hassan is he's so crypto with his
Dan keeps doing the Coke thing where he's like Hassan's not big
Hassan's really small Hassan like doesn't matter anymore I I
beat Hassan
and I just I I love hearing it. Okay, if I could get a
if I could get just a clip compilation of Dan talking about how
irrelevant Hassan is, I would love that. You could inject that
directly into my veins for the next part of this stream. Okay,
hold on. Keep going.
Sounds too crypto with his hat. >> This is Hearn and Pon
thing.
Hold on. >> did he talk any more about the stuff?
No idea. No idea. But it's just funny. Okay, we get some comments
in chat today from Dan. Let's see. Now that Han is banned from
Twitch, the Destiny debate collab is going to happen, right?
All to plan. Talk about something else. 5,000 of those viewers
are me. This is good for Bitcoin. He's got to leave Twitch for
YouTube. The goal has to has to be to keep him on YouTube. That's
a major W. I don't know what you guys are coping about. There's
already a hundred other anti-semites on YouTube.
Uh the goal is to make him make way more money. He's not he literally
can't get ad revenue on Twitch.
Like his his ad revenue from today is more than he would have
made on Twitch in like a month, right? Like his ad revenue for
his stream for today would have been insane without with no super
chats, with no nothing. It would have been insane,
If you guys didn't notice, Hassan was hitting borderline Candace
Owens numbers today. Okay. Borderline Candace Owens numbers for
Hassan.
Okay. Is that it for I swear to God, there's got to be way more
in terms of people talking about Oh, I had one more Asmin Gold
clip, didn't I? Yes. One more Asmin Gold clip. >> How about
that, huh?
>> Wow. Oh, there it is. Right off the >> What a
day, huh? Man, I uh you know, I woke up a little while ago and
uh Oh, geez. I used to pray for times like this. Yep. Yep. I
know. And uh what a lovely day. I know. Like I just uh you know
I've seen some of this going on and it is really
funny
>> over stream rant.
He got his ass banned again. The thing is like he just he couldn't
leave the alone.
>> Couldn't stop talking about him.
>> But no, they're Zionists. Oh, okay. Isn't it crazy how
every time that you talk about what Zionists do and how bad Zionists
are, it's always stereotypes like filing lawsuits and like banking
and like stuff like this. Isn't that crazy? Like what?
That's not what this was.
That's not at all what this was.
That's uh
that's crazy. It turns out Wait, Asmin Gold is doing his patented
move. Watch none of the stuff. Just comment. Just make it up.
Asthmaold is like Vosch but without the orb. Okay. Vos ponders
the orb. He sees into the future and he's just correct. Asold
just makes >> the odds that speaks with the stereotype
just happens to also be a Zionist stereotype. Like what what
are the odds of that? Right. I mean like wow. So uh yeah I did
see this and uh oh my god Monday. Well I don't know. I mean the
thing is that um you know him getting banned for a week over
this. It's like I feel like uh you know this would have never
happened if he didn't use uh you know uh and Zionist his community.
It's not really him. It's like his community and the internet
at large. They they use they say something is Israeli and like
every single time they say something is is Israeli.
That's like saying the with like the a instead of the hard R.
Just
just say it. Just say the word. Don't go and be like, "Oh, it's
Israeli.
It's uh oh, it's Zionist." No.
Okay. Can we find that clip of Asmin Gold going off about Greg
Abbott again?
His uh his his governor being at that pro-Israel event. >> They
do. Just call them out, MAN. THAT'S THE THING. I MEAN, THAT'S
what they want to do. That's what they want to say. Like, just
let them know, man. And that's it. They they trying to talk around
it. And that's the thing is like and what is the odds that every
Israeli and every Zionist stereotype just happens to be a Jew
stereotype, right? What what are the odds of that? And so here's
the reality, right? I see this happen is that this has been against
the rules. They even said explicitly it's against the rules.
I don't know why he keeps doing this, man. I really don't. And
BB Netu got your connection. Yeah, bro. They tried to shut me
down. That the J word is out to get you next. Yeah, you saw it,
man. I even said the name. They tried to shut me down. That's
the way it is. It's the damn uh damn Zionist, huh? These Zionists
keep trying to shut me down. He got suspended. Yeah, I know.
I know all about that. Watermelon felon is gone. I know. Well,
he not a felon, right? But yeah, whatever. And watch the J word.
I know that. Be funny if Israel has been paying us on the 5K.
It's 7K. But uh I
>> Dude, absolutely crazy stuff. >> I think that
you wouldn't be surprised. I mean, I think he's done probably
more to help Israel than hurt it. Uh, he's just he's made it
uh, you know, like whenever you're a person with a lot of baggage,
a lot of I don't I don't think that's true, actually. I think
Israel literally I think people who are pro- Israel have gone
super far out of their way at this point
to like target social media explicitly to not let like these
kind of narratives like flourish
I don't think he's I don't think he's helped. I I think that's
pretty crazy. problems, a lot of stuff going on. And then you're
What's the thought process for haters trying to move Hassan to
YouTube? I don't know. I actually don't know. We're going to
go through that a little bit cuz I I it's just very confusing,
man. Overall, it's just very very very confusing.
Now, this was one of the last updates we got. Hassan with apparently
12,000 US in super chats today. Let me go I'll try to go to playboard
right now. Let's check in on how Hassan's stream did today. Okay.
I want to see the numbers. How did it go? How did How did his
first stream on YouTube go? Platform where he's actually monetized,
by the way, unlike other platforms where he's demonetized, right?
Is a platform where he's actually monetized.
Let's take a look. Uh peak viewership,
146,000
peak concurrent viewers. Okay.
And
66,000 basically average concurrent
Wow.
That it sure seems like they did a great job. So that's 65,000.
That's more than he gets on Twitch, by the way. More than he
gets on Twitch. And not only that,
is getting super chats, too. Currently, am I in Canada for this
or No, I'm in the US. So, currently at $17,000 in revenue on
super chats right now. Timer. Oh, we didn't do timer. Hold on.
Let's reset the timer. Hold on. Oh, timer. Where is it? Over
here. There it is.Oop
There we go. There we go. So, $17,000 in super chats.
2,000 super chats. $17,000.
I don't even think they're tracking memberships. Okay. And I'm
sure he got gifted a lot of memberships. I'm sure a bunch of
people went and added memberships today.
Uh, somebody link me this meme. I will open it up for two seconds.
We'll laugh at it and then we'll move on. Okay.
I will have more concurrent viewership than Hassan by 2025.
137,000
concurrent viewers. Channel not monetized. 15,000 in super chats.
We've seen the higher number now for Hassan today. Now it's 17,000.
Okay. Average concurrent viewers over here.
O.
It's just it's just a big old oof. Okay.
Um, and realistically, if this guy wasn't a total sub, like,
how do I put into words why I don't like this person? Okay, I'll
I'll put it into
Last night,
he heard some some DJ or some DGer told Destiny that I was sending
Msk Destiny documents. Totally made up, totally fabricated. I
don't I don't want to discuss the Destiny [__] with
Msk. I don't want to discuss the Destiny at all. I want to move
on to other things because being involved with that community
is only bad for people. There's no positive. There's no upside
to being involved with that community, right? But he read that.
Okay. He read that somebody told him that I was sending like
Destiny documents to Miskf and he immediately doxed multiple
people in his chat. Like his response was to totally crash out
and dox multiple
That was his response to that information. He didn't check it.
He didn't even make sure. He just docks multiple people and then
somebody tells him like, "Oh no, Misk sent him like the Teetone
transcript,
you know, and so it's like, dude, are you are you okay?" Like
mentally unstable person, man. Totally mentally unstable. It's
very weird.
Anyway, so I don't mind I don't mind the packwatch on him so
much. It seems like appropriate sometimes, man. That's all. You
know, it's it's just appropriate sometimes. Guy's a real piece
of [__]
Anyway, what do we got here? Still looking around.
Let me see. Let me see. Let me see.
I think that might be it for the song segment. I I'm almost ready
to move on to some Techone stuff. Some Pikachu Tech stuff. We'll
see. What was this throwaway clip real quick? Oh, I need to throw
throw away my um pre stream preview stuff. Bro, I almost
>> there's a Jesus Christ. That almost doesn't even look
like Amiru. What the hell? Emiru hints at talking about a big
drama. Hints talk at talking about a big drama. Techone/lari.
Almost didn't go live because I was so tilted. Never really talk
about personal stuff/ drama until I have to. Okay, >> bro.
I almost didn't go live today cuz I was so tilted earlier today.
Oh my god. But I feel fine now, honestly. Yo, Maryro, thank you
for the 18 months. It's It was seeing that charm like it me off
but it's like hard to think about anything else.
>> Why tilted?
>> Oh my gosh.
I'm like still debating if like I actually want to like talk
about this stuff and fully give attention to it.
>> I feel like she's definitely talking about Misgiv's
comments, right? >> So you guys know how like I never really
>> Oh god. Oh [laughter] god.
I didn't get the love for Emirou until I saw A10 Emiru. Okay,
A10 Emiru by Aryan Queen.
We love A10 Emiru here. Okay, >> you guys know how like
I never really like
talk about like personal stuff or like drama on stream and all
unless it's like I kind of like have to for like a certain point.
Well, I would say that like for the most part doing that has
only pros. Like I've never really regretted choosing to be that
kind of content creator. But there is one con that when you don't
say things
or like don't like talk about super personal stuff all the time
or like your feelings about certain things, it leaves people
room to like lie and make up and it's so annoying. But I'm like
I don't think I don't think normal people really like >> it's
like who who cares? Like I'm just I don't know.
No one's that worried about my life unless they're weirdos. So,
I'm like, why even? I don't know. I might still talk about it,
but I'm still deciding.
I swear. Like,
>> bro, just vague posting on like the on an elite tier.
Okay. Just vague posting in a tier of her own right now. Vag
post after vague post after vague post. >> Years. Like
honestly, like probably like five years. I don't know why every
time like something crazy happens people just are like well what
does she think about this and I'm like
>> do I need to like am I like the police or something
like oh what do you mean I didn't was so important to you people
>> I would say when you're Jesus
I would say she's like so so insanely skinny um
I would say when you are friends with people and they are accused
of like fairly monstrous things, especially when they try to
form like you alleging similar things about other people or possibly
similar things about other people.
It's that's people will expect you to comment on that probably.
>> I'm sorry. Yeah. I mean, literally, I feel like literally
every time there has been a situation that like directly involved
me, I have always like talked about it, but it's not. It's like,
>> like I said, I feel like for the most part, it's 99%
pros to choosing not to, you know, be a part of people farming
that kind of stuff. But it does allow people to lie and pretend
to be stupid
and like it's like, bro,
And also assume that they know like everything about my life
and who I'm friends with. It's like bro like use your brain.
Use your brain. >> Oh my gosh.
>> Like they're like what what about this? It's like bro
[laughter] this tweet broke her. Damn. I didn't realize this
uh I didn't realize this Chronic Sonic tweet blew up so hard.
How many appeared on this podcast,
bro? [laughter]
Uh
okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. All right. Yeah. That Oh, and we got
the Let's just do a little bit of slop from this channel real
quick cuz we do also have the TP person. We remember this last
night when we were watching Msk. She was like talking about Msk,
right?
A little bit of slop from this channel real quick cuz we do also
have >> my own stream. God damn it. Stop. Stop. We saw
this last night when Msk was covering the transcript. He was
getting like one guide by people bringing this up. Let's just
see what you >> I highly suggest
if you're going to like talk about content, at least verify that
it's true
cuz then you look like a [__] dumbass.
You shouldn't go trotting around saying someone said this and
not even like have at least your team look into it and verify
that that information is true before you go and spread it around
someone because you can get in some serious trouble spreading
misinformation about someone
when it's not true. You will go on
>> Wow.
Um that could be true. Now, I think with the Lucari stuff, it's
really difficult to you're you're asking people to verify what
just verify that it's actually child before you do before you
say it is. It's like, well, that's a tough one. Um, already the
titles are
Yeah, I don't know.
I I don't know, man. So, if you guys have missed it, I haven't
covered it on stream cuz the techone stuff's been popping off,
but apparently Lucari's come out and said that none of the files
in there are actually child. Some other people said this. Someone
said this to me, too. Someone said I think someone DM'd this
to me on Twitter, and I thought about looking into it, but I'm
like, dude, I'm I'm just not gonna I unfortunately I'm just not
going to go try to verify all of that, right? I I'm sorry. I'm
just not taking that on personally and I didn't really go too
much further into it. If I maybe if I was going to go further
and and talk about Lucari a lot more, I would have gone further
into it. I do think if it were to be true that that were the
case that that one thing had no illegal but that's the other
thing he says is there's nothing illegal in there and it's like
okay there's nothing illegal but like what's in there?
What what are you looking at there? What what is happening there?
There's nothing illegal but what is happening there? H >> stream
and you stream my stream and you make yourself look like you
care about how I feel and like the situation that I've been going
through.
You pretend to care. Pretend to donate.
Pretend to
be there for me when I'm sorry, my DMs are
Pretty sure she's talking about screenshots of her dis of her
in Discord that she claims were fabricated. Oh, okay. Sure, sure,
sure. That could be it. If she's talking about if she's just
talking about screenshots from her Discord or something, which
she does get into in just a second. >> I haven't received
a single message from Misk saying, "Yo, I'm really sorry about
this. What can I do to help you out?" All of it was for show.
All of it was for stream.
Never once did he reach out to me ever in concern about anything.
I'll be honest, I I I could never be accused of this. I said
this person was unbearable as soon as we started listening to
them. So, you know, I can never be accused of this. Thank god
I didn't even fame concerned. I was just like, "Oh, this person's
I hate this. I hate everything about this right now." That never
happened. All he did was just talk about it on
And when I exposed him for the donation thing at my Discord server,
apparently all of these screenshots of me on Discord started
popping up. How how convenient.
He just wants to harass his ex-girlfriend and manipulate the
media,
I guess. So to have fake screenshots
spread about me online
because I just am friends with Emaroo.
Um h
is that why Miz wants to do that? I don't think so. I don't think
I feel like this person doesn't register to him if I had to guess.
I do think he wants to go after people. I just don't think this
person's like at the top of his list to be honest with you. Also,
somebody asked how long she was with Lucari or when did they
break up? I think she broke up with him when the links came out.
I'm pretty sure.
All right. I was supposed to do a cosplay stream today and just
chill and just have a normal stream. But, you
I have angry dudes messaging me on
so I can't do my regular
Am I Am I crazy that I've just never felt the need to like direct
message somebody and be like, "You're a real piece of shit."
I don't know if I've I don't know if I've ever done >> human
degenerate just tipped $5. Okay. Lucari doesn't have seesome
on his
Thank you. On his computer. Yeah. Thank you. Um, dude.
Oh, I just lost my train of thought. Dono. Thank you very much,
though. Appreciate it. >> Do my regular streaming stuff.
And now my streaming manager is going to get mad at me. But it's
okay.
>> I was supposed to do a sponsor today, but I will just
do it tomorrow.
Yeah. I don't know. I just didn't I don't this whatever can't
cosplay because of Twitter. Oh, right. About DMing people. Yeah.
Never I' like I've DM' people I know
like being angry at them, but I I have never DM'd somebody I
have no idea who they are and I've DM' them to be like, "You're
a real piece of
Like, in a little bit we're going to get into the legal mindset
stuff with um with respect to Pink. We're going to get into that.
And I I can't imagine DMing legal mindset to be like, "You're
a total piece of [__] man. You're a total piece of
You better use funny avatars today as your manager. I highly
recommend it. This is my funny avatar. I like this avatar. I'm
rolling with this for a little bit. Okay.
I'm rolling with this for just a little
All right. We're checking uh the Asmin Gold tweet out next. Asmin
Gold talking about Techone and Lucari.
Let's go. Okay, we're going to check this out and then Oh boy.
Do we continue? Did I finish with the Hassan stuff? I think I
might have cut out in the middle of the Hassan clip. Oh, there's
one more thing on the Hassan
Let's We'll do this and then we'll uh we'll get back to the Han
thing.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> You talked to a Hamas Hamas [__]
band today? Yeah. talk a little bit about a technical combat.
I I ain't going to talk I I will say that um you know a lot of
people have been uh you know outspoken wanting me to talk about
the techone of the Lucari thing. I'm going to just kind of lay
this out straight up flat out just straight like 100%. Uh I'm
in a lawsuit right now. I'm being sued for defamation and any
comments that I could make about either of those cases could
be used as evidence to further create a case against me in the
existing defamation lawsuit that I have now. And so the reason
why I'm not speaking on it or saying anything about it is because
I don't want to give that any more oxygen. I don't want to prolong
that at all. And the only thing I want to do is be over with
it. And then as soon as I'm over with it, then I'm going to talk
about it. But I can't talk about that at all because of the lawsuit.
And that's the reason why it can be used as additional information
and it can be leveraged as additional uh you know basically arguments
to prove any sort of a point. >> Okay. No. Now, this is
why this is another reason. Actually, this response right here
is another reason I want to go through the schizophrenia stuff.
I believe there's no reason Asminold can't comment on the schizophrenia,
right? Asminold can comment. We could source it entirely from
legal mindset, all the schizophrenia stuff, right? You don't
have to talk about misk at all. You can just talk about techone
only.
So he says he doesn't want to comment, but we can totally make
this disjoint from Miskf in a way where you could comment completely.
You could be totally fine to comment and you would obviously
be lying if you wouldn't comment,
right?
Like right now it's not quite so obvious, but as soon as I put
together all that schizophrenia information, I make the tweet
and I can say, "Hey, do you want to comment on this? This seems
pretty crazy, right? that you were like totally boosting somebody
who is an unmedicated diagnosed schizophrenic who has hallucinations
and has had multiple instances where he's nearly harmed somebody,
right? Don't you think it's a problem? Don't you think like he
has to get treatment immediately?
How is he not getting treatment? How is he going live on Sunday,
which by the way is happening? I didn't pull this up. This is
actually the first thing in my docket and I didn't even pull
it up. What am I doing with my life? Guys, Techone has announced
officially
live 9:00 a.m. CST Sunday, February 1st. See y'all then.
Wow. Hectone live on Sunday.
Amazing. Amazing. Amazing. Amazing.
On kick. Who knows? Probably YouTube, I would imagine. YouTube
kick.
Early stream. Uh maybe maybe late stream. I'm not totally sure
which way we go after that.
Early or late stream? Not totally sure.
He's banned on Twitch, right? I actually don't remember if he's
banned on Twitch currently anymore or not.
There's no way he doesn't get baited worked up into violating.
Um,
well, I mean, at some point he's got to go live again, right?
At some point he's got to talk about stuff. At some point he's
got to try to do his job. As difficult as that'll be for him.
What are the penalties when he inevitably inevitably violates?
Um, depends on how bad the violation is, I believe. Is it $4,000
fine and potentially a couple months in jail if it's his first
offense, his first
It can be jail time. Yep.
How do you come back from this? Um,
he's going to focus on the same things legal mindset did, which
might be a reason for us to go to the legal mindset stream, right?
He'll focus on like, oh, this person was crazy. They like wanted
to be with me.
Man,
I
feel like you're so right. Oh, I know I'm so right about this,
but um, sorry. I feel like
I don't know how he goes through and doesn't he can't really
talk about the case, the specifics of the testimony and if anybody
knows the specifics of the testimony, they get like totally cooked
on this. Oh, I also forgot. We done with the as we're not. We
got to finish this clip and then
>> possibly on to the techone stuff. So, let's finish this
on then. >> That's the reason why I'm not talking about
it is purely because of the lawsuit. That's the only reason.
If it wasn't because of that, I'd be talking about it. So, just
keep that in mind. As soon as the lawsuits over, we're going
to talk about we can talk about a lot of things, right? But like
that's it. So, I just want to let you guys know that um you know,
it's not like I condone or support any of that or anything else.
Uh but I cannot go and make any comments or anything else just
for that reason. Uh I I'm not going to give any fuel to the fire.
Just keep that in mind. And uh I finish that and uh you know,
you know, in the short term, I see it does make me look bad.
I'm not talking about it. Sometimes there's you've got to eat.
that's the way it is. But, you know, I've got to play the long
game and I've got to do what's best for me. So, uh that's really
the reason why. Uh hopefully people can respect that. Hopefully
people understand that. And uh that's really all there is to
it. And >> total total cope. Total cope. Total cope. Total
cope. Total cope. Total cope. Total. >> If you read the
court filings and everything
of the lawsuit, you'll understand what my trepidation is. And
you want to get into that, go ahead. So, it's all public information,
right? I mean, like, what the So, there you go. And uh it's fair.
Yeah. No, I I just want to let y'all know like I I want to let
y'all know that that's where I'm at. That's what I'm doing, right?
And everything of the Techone suit, you'll understand what my
trepidation is. I don't understand what his trepidation is to
tell you the truth. I actually don't get it. >> And so,
uh just, you know, don't think it's apathy. This is a tactical,
uh legal decision that I have to make. And
I apologize for that. I do. I >> That's cope. That's cope.
That's cope. It's the same cope everybody else does. Bro, I think
a lot of streamers are going to want to start getting sued so
that whenever there's something coming up that they don't want
to talk about, regardless of how connected it is to their lawsuit,
they'll just get to go, "Well, guys, I have a lawsuit going,
so I can't comment on that." It's like next level tech. Every
rich streamer wants to have some lawsuit because whenever something
comes up, regardless of if it's connected or not, they can just
go, "Hey guys, I'm in I'm in litigation. I couldn't possibly
comment on that." Wait, it has nothing to do with your litigation,
though. Oh, you don't know that. You don't know that. You don't
know that. You don't know that, sir. Excuse me. You're You're
unaware. You don't know that.
Come on, man. Come on, dog. Come on, dog.
All right, we have one final Hassan comment. Apparently, he doubles
down on
comments from yesterday that got him banned. [laughter] This
time, bro.
This time I said ultra
I saidbody is pig.
I mean, he said it again.
You're saying it is a tactical decision, just not a legal one.
Sure. Yeah, that's what I'm saying. That Asbold is is basically
saying this tactically. Yeah,
I I can say like Yeah, I'm just saying he's lying. Yeah, I don't
know if that was confusing.
Ban got reduced as well. I think
7-day ban went right down to 12 hours. Oh, is he already unbanned
from Twitch? Oh, that's unfortunate. He's going to be banned
at the end of the day.
Oof. Oof. By the way, does he say like, "I totally agree with
that message." I hear him say it again. Is this a double down?
Like, I am I said it and I I'm happy I said it, which I totally
believe he would. I just didn't hear it here. >> For this
time, bro, what this time? >> I said ultraist pigs.
>> I said anybody is ultra pig.
Yeah, he literally just said why he got banned, right? He literally
said what he said to got ban to get banned.
That's not a double down. That's categorically not a double down.
Is this person
doubling down is saying and that's based and I'll do it again.
That's based and there's nothing wrong with it. He just sounded
precisely
what he said. That's all.
Sounded proud. [laughter] He sounded proud
for this. I said ultra is pig
is ultra pig.
H
okay. All right.
All right. Okay.
Wow. Okay.
That's it for the son ban topic, I believe. Let's move on to
the pink legal mindset stuff. All right.
He spit when he said pigs, did he?
>> Very cool. Very cool.
All right. Let's go to the pink stuff, I guess. I suppose. Oh,
well, we'll we'll cover a little bit of techone stuff. Yeah,
cover a little bit of techone stuff. Let's see. There's this
um there's the Pink tweet from last night. Pink
right here. Let me open up Pink's Twitter.
It's uh boom boom boom this tweet right here. Okay, this is the
lawyer legal mindset or this this is the lawyer legal mindset
posted an unredacted leaked documents that were meant to be sealed
live to thousands of people to put doc to dox me putting my family
in danger. Okay, so legal mindset went over it. He included things
like I believe he included like her address and okay
who this is uh this is the person who got the protective order
against
against Tekone. It's Pink Chu okay
this pink chew. Okay, this is Pink Chu.
Did she get paid or just a protective order? She got lawyer fees
and her lawyer's fees were like 15 grand. It's probably not very
much money to her to be honest.
scared of He is terrified of Yes, we did the whole transcript
last night, guys. We might read a little bit more today. A little
bit more on the schizophrenia parts of his transcript. Okay,
we might go back over that in a little bit. Okay, people remember
now. So, this is Pink. He made this comment. Uh, she says, "I
was going to stay quiet and worked with authorities, but he is
in Thailand. It's disgusting how someone would recklessly review
documents that say unofficial on them because they aren't for
public and aren't for the public and read them with disregard
to anyone's safety." Now, I do think probably at bare minimum,
the act of like
not putting her address out there is quite important, right?
I would It's pretty up to put her address out there, guys. You
know what I'm saying?
All the Fentes clippers are logging us on now.
Um, and then not sure what I could say, but I'm told the county
is doing an investigation on the matter. Thank you to all the
streamers that did take the time to redact information or not
share at all. Now, it will be a long process for me to move,
but maybe it's a new chapter for me. Yeah, it's it sucks. Um,
it does suck, man. Sucks quite badly.
You reckon legal mindsets still techone tech and claim schizophrenia?
Well, he's going to claim something probably.
Yeah, I do think filing a privacy strike was the right call here
if you were going to do something.
Um, so there's basically some concerns. So, Legal Mindset had
responses to this, right?
Got this one from earlier today.
It goes like this. Okay. So, Shimu started tweeting at legal
mindset on some of his. Okay. Oh, we need the legal mindset response
as well. Legal mindset response right here. Oh, [__]
Got to be careful cuz I don't know if you noticed this, but when
you get doxed, the funny thing is is
useless human beings will go to your comments and they'll start
trying to comment your docs under like all of the posts so everybody
sees it, right? So, I think what what's what happened here and
what I saw or observed a little bit was,
are all of Legal Mindset's fans in comments trying to put her
her docks out there all over the place? Seems a little little
weird. No, seems a little odd. I personally feel like you probably
shouldn't do that, right? Um, also
I see
esports Batman in chat saying that like, oh, you could report
him to the county or to the bar. I don't know if he even practices
law. I don't know if he has any plan to practice law in America
again. Maybe it matters. I don't think it really does. So, it's
it's kind of you'd have to report him to like some Asian like
the Thai bar or something. I don't even know. And then does he
even do legal work anymore? Is it all his channel? Is it all
just influencer work? Is there any way to report him to something
like that?
Anyway, so after Pink complained, Legal Mindset This Morning
says, "No amount of gaslighting or brigading will stop publication
and open discussion of open court documents. I will also offer
these documents to anyone, whether proink, protect, or neutral,
to anyone requesting them politely by email or DM. Attempting
to hide what you've discussed in open court is a telltale sign
of bad faith."
That's not what she's asking for. She actually had no problem
with people reporting on this, right? She had no problem with
people going through that transcript. She had a problem with
somebody publishing her address, publishing her full name in
connection to having a a chat filled with Teone supporters, right?
That's her problem. This is a total this is like a total straw
man of what her issue was. Like pretty clearly so.
Like obviously so this is not that is bad faith, right? Her problem
isn't people covering her court case. She's totally fine with
that. She doesn't want her medical info discussed. She filed
a protective order, a a seal on this. Well, I'd say totally fine.
I'm sure she's like uncomfortable with it, but she's she's not
like, you know, freaking out on everybody who discussed this.
She's freaking out a legal mindset for putting her address out
there.
Okay,
this is such a weird post. You made a whole ass video about Hassan
watching a vid review public reviewing public FC filings and
legal mindset potentially criminal charges he should get. Oh,
dude, what? I forgot about that. legal mindset Hassan docs.
Oh, this is the live. Hold on. This is the live. We want the
Is there fact fast facts on this or something?
Oh, I don't know if we got fast facts on this. We've just got
two streams.
Just two streams
called Hutch versus Assan.
Okay, hold on. Hold on. Uh, Hutch
versus Hassan.
Oh, fast backs. >> Hassan and everything else.
>> We'll check this out as well. This will be very important
to look at. Oh my
Legal mindset. Doc says a victim of assault. A victim found,
you know, of somebody found liable for her assault. A victim
of stalking. Certainly stalking of a totally mentally deranged,
mentally ill psycho. Right. and legal mindset doxes her. Very
cool. >> They're all kind of coming out of >> Well,
sorry. We're not going to check this out yet. We need to keep
reading the tweets. Okay. Sunlight is always the best disinfectant.
He says, by the way, sunlight is always the best disinfectant.
I watched the whole live. They want to act like you doxed her
when you didn't even and even show her phone number. You didn't.
And even show her phone number was redacted. So, and everything
else is public records to anyone. Correct. All narrative farming
by framing. All narrative framing by bad faith actors. You did
a great job, brother. Those people are just mad that the narrative
slipped away and they have no way to put the genie back into
the bottle. Keep it up. Do not stop even for a moment to worry
about these low lives. Deis Volultz,
bro. I Okay, can someone go to the legal mindset stream and time
stamp the part where
where Pink is is what? Recrossed. Not recrossed. What is the
uh it's the examination that follows from her lawyer where she
asks to clarify how that suck your dick statement came about
cuz I want I want that and I want I want two timestamps if you
can find them. If somebody could do this real quick I'd appreciate
it. I want the the part where he reads Oh, he did get rid of
the VOD. We could probably go over it but
redirect. Sure, sure. Sure. Yeah, redirect. So, what I'm looking
for, I'm sure he'll publish it. Is his reaction to those two
things because to me that was like their best piece of evidence
was Pinky Chu sent this text saying, "Oh, I want to suck your
dick." And then you find out the circumstances are Pink actually
said to a friend that Teeone had forced her to him and he freaked
out
through a whole temper tantrum, sat her down and was like, "You
need to text me right now that you want to suck my dick.
I see it. Hold on. Well, maybe he put a video up and he took
the live down.
I see. Yeah, I see it. I don't see it
So, maybe it's unprivated already. Maybe it was privated while
they were adding redactions or something. Maybe stuff's redacted
now or some [__]
Okay. All right. Anyway,
so Legal Mindset tweeted these things. Shimu responded to him.
Okay. Says, "It's not the transcript. It's what was accessible
via the court portal, which you brought up on stream first. If
I recall correctly, the county shut down uh the county shut down
its accessibility via court portal after they found out about
it." And Techone or sorry, Shimu posts his email with the county
saying exactly like basically this shouldn't have ever been viewable.
Shouldn't have ever been visible. It was supposed to be private
and it's actuallyed up that anybody was able to access or review
it. Wrong. Okay.
So apparently legal mindset blocked him for this. As we go through
the day,
he continues, "Absolute coward. Legal mindset not only blocked
me but hid my reply, correcting him on the court document situation
with TechOne. Zero integrity. It's important the court acknowledged
that the documents he showed were not meant to be public."
They find out if people got access. Yes, it was a database error
that they actually fixed. They actually patched it pretty quickly.
You can't get to that portal anymore. It doesn't just let you
into that portal anymore. They fixed it pretty quickly. So shockingly,
I've never seen you so uncontrollably like a little [__]
So you still have that going for you.
Oh, I see. Legal mindset was crying like a little [__]
apparently.
Okay. And then we get this one. Legal mindset privated his stream
doxing techno's victim and leaking what were supposed to be private
court docs with zero redactions. This comes after Legal Mindset
claimed he did nothing wrong, yet he removed it. So maybe this
tweet upset him and he unprivated cuz I've got the full thing
here. I've got the full 3-hour stream.
3 hours 107. Well, it was 3 hours 107. Now it's 3 hours 106.
So this one's 3 hours 107. Now it's up in 3 hours 106. I wonder
if he was processing some YouTube backend thing and that it would
have removed something. Something was edited and now he put it
back up.
How hard is it to come out and be like, "Oops, my bad."
Uh, pretty difficult for influencers. Pretty hard, man. Pretty
basically impossible. Almost entirely impossible, actually. How
hard is it to do that? Admit fault is an influencer. Yeah, it's
basically impossible.
Uh, hold on. We had a message from Twitch chat that I missed.
Let me see if I can find it. Nope. Oh, there it is. If she moves,
doesn't that mean that Tekone would have an updated protection
order with her new address, which he would just leaked to Legal
Mindset again? Um, well, he didn't leak this. We don't know that
he leaked this to Legal Mindset. Okay, we don't know that he
directly leaked it. We've seen this, but okay. Is this tech Don't
explain the exploit.
Oh, Legal Mindset is having a total breakdown in tears. After
being chased by imaginary women within Thailand, Legal Mindset
begins to show cracks in his psyche. Cuz
when you're when you're super depressed,
when you're super depressed, it's hard to do this. It's hard
to do this [__] you know.
And um I love you guys. [laughter] It's really good. It's really
good to be back.
It's really good to be back.
So, thank you guys. Appreciate that. Oh,
You guys made me cry. [__] Okay. Appreciate you guys.
I gotta lock in. I gotta lock in. I love you guys.
>> All right. Sorry. That's just It's been really It's
been really difficult for me to come back sometimes and do content.
>> I'm glad that he was able to get his, you know, his
mental back up by doxing Teone's victim. I'm glad that that that's
what always restores my me my mental. Okay. Gonna find somebody's
victim. I'm going to with their life. That always makes me feel
better when I'm in a in a you know a deep downward spiral of
depression. Oh, there's a there's a victim of all that could
die. Let's go. I'm back. I'm back, baby. >> Appreciate
coming back. >> I really do. >> It means a lot to
go.
>> It really does.
>> It really does because, you know, content creation really
[__] sucks sometimes. It really [__]
sucks. And sometimes you feel like you're not going to be able
to come back
and it's really difficult. It's like super difficult.
So I appreciate that. I really do.
I really [__] do.
Thanks, dude. I appreciate I appreciate all you guys. And look
at me. People are going to make fun of me be like look at mindset
[__] crying on stream. I don't give a [__]
It's [snorts] difficult, you know, and it's real and it's that's
why I have sympathy for people, you know? because I go through
this [__] too. You know, I go through this [__]
too. And um
>> you know, there's a there's a time in which you don't
you don't want to stream and you you like you feel you have to
Uh I just feel no empathy for this person anymore. Just that
the way they handled this is just very I just feel a total lack
of empathy now. I felt it before. I totally eased up before.
Now, he's the one saying that this wasn't doxing. It's all just
public legal documents. Okay. Now, keep in mind FC filings, public
legal documents. Public documents. Okay. Government documents.
Apparently, he posted a fast fact video. Hassan versus Hutch.
>> This clip. So, if you didn't see this clip, I'm going
to play it for you guys again. This is from the Fast Facts, but
I'm going to play it one more time. This is the uh the doxing
incident. Now, of course, adjacent to this doxing and >> I
just tuned in and he's crying. Yeah, he was crying. He was crying.
>> Is of course stuff that can be considered defamatory.
So, there's other statements that are outside him showing this
that are coupled together could be considered potentially defamatory,
right? But let's just show the thing that really pissed everybody
off. >> Yeah. Dylan Burns,
Hunter Avalon, Hutch, Destiny's own personal chef. Like, >> mind
you, real quick, real quick. Uh, did see how he says Dylan Burns?
He says this like a person that he knows. The funny thing is,
and there's a separate video that he claims later to not even
know who this guy is, right? Oh, I didn't even know who Dylan
Burns was. Like, and he he does a very good job of playing an
idiot. Hassan is I have to give him credit where credit is due.
Hassan does a very good job of playing a zero brain cell. He
does an excellent job of that. I can't take credit away from
that. He He does an excellent job of playing stupid. So,
Uh he does pretend to really not know who these people are even
though of course he knows who they are right it's he's not ignorant
>> Hunter Avalon Hutch Destiny's own personal chef
>> like this is this is >> what's the problem this
is what took >> in legal mindsets and the pack actually
did uh unironically and so he's showing their name city state
zip code so he's showing a lot of their information which you
can use to track them down so their legal names or city states
zip codes able people are definitely able to find them off of
that and
>> okay and that's a problem or
wait what's the no there is no street address here but I believe
he might have posted her street address so what is how can he
say I'm totally fine and Hassan was in the wrong way this is
from an FEC filing so you know this is something that once again
while it's public yes it's technically public It's something
that most people aren't digging into and getting. So, it's while
it is information that's out there, most people don't don't think,
oh, someone's going to dig into the FC filings
and they're going to get this information and they're going to
throw
>> it out there. Most people don't think that. And and
most people like you you probably have your name in some disclosure
somewhere at some point that's a mandatory disc. So, he seems
to totally understand the issue here, right? He seems to completely
understand it 100%. >> I know this because I did corporate
disclosures and there's a lot of things you need to disclose.
Oh, here's the people that gifted us over X amount of money.
Your name's out there somewhere publicly, right? And someone
just brings this up on a stream of 30,000 people, whatever. That's
going to be re-watched by millions, right? That's not what [clears throat]
you signed up for when you engage in that behavior, right? And
I'm not saying that's that's necessarily the case here, right?
But what I'm saying is there's a lot of lists online of names
and that I don't think that especially under the California criminal
>> Did my sub not announce? Uh individual subs don't announce
because they run over a lot of the time. But alien mode, thank
you for the 20 months. I appreciate it, man. I appreciate it.
and the interpretation based on my conversations with California
lawyers. I don't think that opens you up to consenting to having
your information put out there, particularly as an enemy,
>> particularly to an audience that has some unfused members,
RIGHT? >> OH. OH, he totally totally totally totally gets
it, right? He like 100% totally gets it.
Oh man, I actually >> Oh, here's the people.
By the way, this is from an FEC definitely able to find them
on. So there zip code uh unironically. >> And so he
hold on right here. 140
time stamp. Can we get somebody? Can we get somebody? Who's it?
Where's my
Where's my clippers?
Could have been you.
Uh, yeah. But I want that smoke, dog. I want I ain't want that
smoke, dog. You got me. You feel me? I want that smoke.
Okay, let the other person get that smoke. I want that [__]
[__] that [__]
>> Also, the person messaging me, you're it's now your
job to clip this. Okay, I'm giving you two times. >> Don't
think that opens you up to articulate to an audience that has
like people members, right?
uh raise a bunch
money off of people who thought that they were uh giving money
to to a a um a political action committee that was going to go
around and and you know do door doornocking campus operations
which they did. >> Yeah. So so that's the that's the doc
that's the doxing stuff. So obviously they're people that he
frames as his opponents right? They're not people that he is
friendly with. They're people that you know if you don't like
them which he is telling you I don't like them you would an unhinged
person might go and get them right might go and get them. And
so we have two things from Hutch. One is from uh earlier um from
a day or so ago and then another one is today and um Hutch actually
uh really really is having some problems with this and he's considering
a defamation lawsuit which is the new part. But let's play this
older video and then we'll play the new one. >> Was he
doing these baseless accusations? He doxed us.
He doxed us.
He docked. It's like prominently
He docks that. It's like prominently featured on his screen.
I can't believe that Andrew just says clearly. Okay, so we've
got it. You take public documents, you post that public information
even for a stream or a YouTube video. That is doxing. So Andrew
doxed her. Andrew doesn't disagree that he doxed her, right?
Like
hello. Uh
hello. Are we like I don't know what to say, man. I mean like
I reported the VOD as he as he should. As he should because it
is a violation of Twitch's doxing policy, which by the way says
that even if the information is public, that's not okay. So,
which by the way is California law, too.
We're going to look at the laws again. This guy's such a scumbag,
man. He's such a scumbag.
Now,
I don't really care about the law. I care that like
like it's it's up that Pink went and got a protective order.
The entire point, okay, here's the entire point of all of her
civil legal filings. it is that Teeone is crazy and his audience
is crazy. She doesn't want anything to do with him or his audience.
Legal mindset knows that he's got a lot of overlap with Teeone.
He knows he's going to take Teone's side and he publishes that
information to Tees's audience. While Teone has the protective
order, you as Te's friend publish all of this information on
her to an audience that is sympathetic to Tee the exact crazy
fs slurs that she's trying to avoid. Right?
That's what's upsetting to her. She is very concerned about this
such that she went and filed this protective order. She got it.
Right? And now you've robbed her of the thing she's seeking with
that protective order. You took her victory and you on it. That's
what's upsetting here, right?
You took her victory in court and you actually ruined it for
her. You you took it and you did the exact thing that that order
is meant to prevent immediately.
Right. That's why just in case anybody's wondering why somebody's
upset here. That's what's upsetting,
right? You know you are going to be on the other side of the
issue. You know what you're going to do. Tell us to call in.
I don't even know who's talking. Is it somebody that I have removed
from the overlay? Might be.
Is somebody talking? Tell which to call
>> Wait, who are you talking about, man?
>> I don't even know who you're talking >> It it
No says the information has to be private. just tell legal public
quote unquote public information
somewhere on the internet can be used to harass
>> the VOD is still up you know like you can find the VOD
on his channel I reported the VOD I sent an email to like Twitch
support >> and now he should send a police report to California
>> I added dude
>> dude like if he if if there's no consequence for this
>> when Hassan does the crime It's actually the worst.
When Hassan does a crime, you need to get the police involved.
You are a total piece of [__] man. You're a total
piece of [__] dude.
But when it's me doing it, well, no. I listen, that's publicly
available information. Actually, if you want that hidden, it
means you're guilty.
Means you're guilty, bro. I don't understand how TeeOne didn't
tell people. If I'm Techone in that situation, which I wouldn't
be, but hypothetically, if I were in that situation, I'd tell
my friends, "No, no, no, no, no. I'm going to walk. I'm going
to walk, man. Don't cover it. Don't cover it. Don't try to defend.
No, it's just going to look worse. Don't keep publicizing all
the schizophrenia stuff. That's it's actually up. Don't do it,
man. Please don't do it.
Oh, um, hold on. There tweeted this.
I kind of I want to be
God. Hold on. I need to pull this off because I'm uh just check
and see if there's any other responses here.
Looking looking looking.
did um
Oh, so [laughter] no miss. NO,
I just got something out of a reply
Hold on.
Uhoh. Uhoh.
Looks like Looks like I was right again, unfortunately.
Oh, no. We missed this yesterday.
Oh, wait. Did we miss it?
Oh, never mind. It's a draft document. It's proposed order. I
see. It's a proposed order.
Somebody Somebody somebody asked if if anybody commented on um
Asmagold getting the order granted to dismiss. So, Asigold's
trying to get his um the claims against him dismissed from Misgif's
defamation case. I saw a comment there. And Asig Gold, there's
a document where Asmin Gold is trying to do this. Hold on, let
me pull it up here. We
This is just the motion, but this is a this is a draft motion.
This is like a proposed draft of the motion to dismiss. It's
not. So, this got filed in court, but this is not them saying
that they are actually granting this. It is a draft motion as
in if you were to grant this motion that we're filing, here's
what it would look like. Thank you.
Okay. So, sorry. I was looking at that under a tweet comment
with the legal mindset stuff and I was like, "Oh, no, Miz." But
it's fine. It's fine. We're fine. We're safe. We're good. We're
all
So
basically when Shimu
accuses this guy of doxing here. Okay.
Andrew starts hiding the comments.
The blowing time stamp for legal mindset. Wait, is this the later
one? Vin, thank you. If this is the later
I need to I'm just trying to figure out. So I'm on the side here.
I'm just trying to figure out in the legal mindset thing. I'll
keep keep playing this video for a little bit. What I'm doing
in the background right now is I'm trying to
figure out where he says her name so that I don't cover her name
at all.
And
I do want to respond to this cuz I do think it's important to
see how he handles that cuz I remember he was freaking out when
this first got brought up. Brain, is this the the last time stamp
of him reading like the the redirect?
Oh, I have it muted. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Yes, it is. All right. All right. All right. Now,
let me just check the transcript one more time.
wait, did he not read any of the techone stuff yet? He didn't
read any of the schizophrenia stuff.
Did he ignore it?
>> sorry. This is >> like I don't know what are there
just like there's just no rules. Like I don't understand is a
blatant violation
of Twitch's doxing policy. Like if you go to their policy,
this is what it says about doxing, >> which we'll read
later, but I've got this pulled up as well. This is correct.
>> Doxing of any kind is prohibited by Twitch's community
guidelines, even if the perpetrators only expose information
available via the public record. >> So there you go. So
there you go. Even if it's in the public record, which is the
defense that everybody's going to bring up is that it's, oh,
it's in the public record. It's in the public record, right?
Uh yeah, that's still against their policy. So obviously and
we already know Dan Clansancy is not going to take action on
that, right? However, the police department >> never put
the No, I didn't have the po I didn't dude, I slept. I slept
and then I got up and then I basically grabbed links and I started
streaming. I like read some stuff and I started streaming. So
no, I never put that post up. No, I have not done it yet. I will
put it up. I'm going to do the research for it on stream because
I want to grab a couple of the clips of him talking about like
the the effects of schizophrenia. I want to look for that. If
you guys want to look for clips on that, we should actually do
that as well. Now, real quick, I don't super care. I We've made
our point with this how Andrew is like a total hypocrite. That
would also be interesting. Okay. Would also be quite interesting.
But what I'm super interested in right now is doing this other
stuff. Okay.
>> Oh, hello.
>> We've got 10 gifted from Mad NLT. Let's go. It's two
more hours on the stream. You love to see it. You love to see
it. Thank you so much, Matt. I really appreciate it, man. Thank
you. Thank you. Now, let's check out his responses to this stuff.
I don't know. I maybe I'll just put I'll put the thing up because
I don't want to I don't want it to be messed up. So, let's just
let's just put the filter on. Also, I got the filter today anyway.
So, why not grab the filter?
Okay, we're going to do this one
like this. Yeah, we'll just do it like that. Boom. There's the
filter right there, guys. Oh my god. Isn't it cool? Now I can
pull this legal mindset stuff over onto my stream and we don't
have to worry about him doxing people cuz it's So the next instance
of her name comes up about 20 minutes later. So this is going
to start with
them asking about her
um the the text. Okay.
Rip my sub.
Uh, wait. What do you mean rip your sub >> thing as a thank
you? Can I >> Oh, yeah. Karaoke just individually sucky
sucky. >> So, basically, do you recall texting John? That's
techone
before you went into this hospital. Sorry. Last thing is a thank
you. Can I sucky dick tonight? >> I suck. Sorry, I'm wrong
there. Can I sucky your dick tonight? Right.
>> Um, okay.
>> uh, Space Ghost, thank you for the gifted sub to the
guy told to individually sub. No doubt. Yes, to Kuryoko. Thank
you. >> All right. >> Thank you. REJECTED. BLOCKED.
You cannot individually sub Kyoko.
It's Space Ghost was like, "No, that I I got the gift right here.
>> This is what he instructed me to do."
But did you send the text message? Yes.
>> Oh, this is what he instructed me to do. So, we don't
really bear down on that, >> just to be clear. So, >> wouldn't
that be Shouldn't you like be interested in
Wouldn't you be interested? Oh, hold on. Wait. Is this the right
time stamp? I think it is.
>> Oh, this is Hold on. >> This is it. Okay, it's
fine. I'm not going to read I'm not going to go. >> I understand
the textbook. John instructed you to send him a text message
asking that you could suck his dick that night. Yes. He told
me I needed to ask to suck his dick to show he could trust me
because I needed to reach out to another girl and talk about
what he'd been doing. What date was that? June 28th. That was
a month before hospitalization. That was the night before. No
hospitalization in July. Uh I'm sorry. June July 28th. Okay.
Thank you. Judge may approach. What's the date? June July 23rd.
I don't know if she can authenticate that. Judge may approach.
You may.
Oh Jesus.
wait. Why did this
Christ? Okay.
Um, so hold on. I need to read
I need to read the next parts that I can't even get his whole
thing here for. Okay. So,
is it an accurate representation of the conversation that you
had with John? I believe she says yes, it's fair and an accurate
copy. Yes. entered into with no objections. Uh, somebody you
say
love you. Um, Pink, you say love you. What can you And then what
do you call that? An emote. An emoji. Yes. Sorry. I'm just reading
this cuz it says her name a couple times here. Now, hold on.
I I actually messed up here because I came close to letting this
This is so hard.
God damn it.
Sorry, I'm looking at this. He says the name like multiple times
here. So, it's basically them going through the the
text here,
the day before.
Okay.
You say, "Love you." What do you call that? An emote.
You say
>> love you. And then what I'm trying to make sure I don't
get anything. >> So they get a love you with an emoji,
right? What does the emoji signify?
Happy. Nervous. Right.
Okay. I think you're having a Okay. Hope you're having a good
day. Sorry. Last thing. As a thank you. Can I sucky?
I assume you meant our I assume you meant your tonight. Then
another emoji. What is that significant? a mouth opening emoji.
Can I sucky our tonight with a mouth opening emoji?
Okay. Okay. And this was a day before you went into Austin Oaks.
Yes. And when you went into Austin Oaks, they did a screening
process. Is that fair? They would have. Judge, may I approach
and introduce all the records?
Yes. This is the excerpts. Hold on. I'm gonna take a super chat
break here. Uh greetings mental issues
oblivious about stuff and it's supposedly obvious. Yeah, that's
true. Still sus about the time gap. Perception after that long
time isn't reliable. Yeah. Yeah. So, there is some possibility
about the mental health issues playing in here. I agree. She
loved you long time with that text,
Bro, I
like just that's that's an indication of the type of audience
he's got, by the way, that they will they will like literally
as people who hate her denigrate her, right? Uh yeah, some definite
definite mixed signals there. That's without a doubt going on
for
continuing here. Um the the exer.
This is the first part. I see. Okay. Okay.
Are voluminous. I have them on a flash drive. Judge, I don't
have any objection to the entire
>> flash drive.
Uh, judge, I don't have any objection to the entirety of the
records coming in. Uh, correct. Can we take a comfort
>> Uh, and then they take a break cuz she's talking this.
This is like a little awkward for her. They take a break. Then
he her name again. And then >> discussing you're going
into Austin Oaks. Yes. And before you went to Austin Oaks, you
sent John a series of text messages and you guys had a text conversation
about your decision to go. Sorry that this is kind of messy going
through this. It is kind of messy. It has to be kind of messy
because I don't want to put the information out there that she
doesn't >> Austin. Is that correct? >> Trying to
be extra careful. >> And that's what we see on the screen
behind us. Is that fair? That's Yes. Our discussion. Yes. And
you said I really need a friend right now. I think I need to
go to a mental hospital. My mom doesn't answer. I didn't know
if the medication I'm giving I'm having a hard time. I need to
see a doctor. Figuring it out right now. packing my bags, heading
to mom's. I hope you see this, but I'm going to do the right
thing and get a full psych evaluation and get some real help.
I love you so much. I'm sorry if I ever hurt you, and I can't
wait to come back to feeling better. I love you.
So, they're trying to paint this as as like this is what's happening.
Now there was you could tell Pink was trying to respond and say
actually like he he asked me to text him that and then you they
leave out the context of why. So they leave they add a little
bit like oh I told a friend about this and he said I if I trust
if I'm going to trust you you need to text me this but they left
out the rest of the context which Pink's lawyers come in and
fill this out in redirect. Now I think we could go to redirect.
We have a time stamp here. I think I'm good on redirect. I don't
think I've got any of the um the docs information here.
I don't think so.
Yes. So, this is on redirect. So, we hear all of this of the
circumstances before she goes the night before she goes to this
Austin Oaks. Okay. We hear the circumstances of it a little bit
here, but not really. You get the impression that she really
liked Teo and everything was good. And then you hear about the
fight they had the day before, right, that precipitated that
text a little bit later in the lawsuit. And I want to see how
Legal Mindset reacts to it. So, let me make sure the filter is
still working. It is. Okay.
>> Oh, I got this muted. My bad. My bad. My
>> Um, all right. There was a reference to a text message
that she sent him asking >> It's a little further once
we get to Yeah. A little further in the lawsuit. job right before
the Austin Oaks stay. Do you recall that? Yes. Uh, can you explain
to the court how that text came to be? Are you talking about
the
>> Okay. All right. Little >> awkward. We'll put
one in the square jar for that. Uh, I originally was trying to
confide in a girl that was a mutual friend. Uh, okay. When was
that? When did you try to confide in her?
The blog.
Okay. I believe it was possibly a week before that text or I
don't remember. Okay. Uh it was a little bit after the first
time we broke up. Okay. Then what happened? I just told her that
he wouldn't that he would make me give him a job and she freaked
out. And I'm like, "It's all fine. It's not a big deal." And
I got scared because I didn't know if I could trust her. He then
uh the next day sat me in his office and sat me in a chair. And
he's like, "I'm going to get you on a phone. I'm going to step
inside and out." and he stepped outside the office and he said,
"You're gonna tell me everything you told her in detail. I want
to know if you're lying and we're gonna and we're gonna" So he
sat her down
in a chair like he's Jack Bower. Okay.
WHAT DID YOU TELL HER?
Grabs grabs like a ring light, puts it directly IN HER FACE.
WHAT DID YOU TELL HER? YOU'RE GOING TO TELL ME EVERYTHING YOU
TOLD HER. WE HAVE WAYS OF MAKING YOU TALK.
RIGHT. This is the This is the scene that's playing up in my
head now, okay? With Techone.
>> Have her on the phone back and forth and find out all
the information. You're going to text me that you want to suck
my dick or else I'm not going to trust
So, he's having this whole meltdown fight where she I think she
still is like really hot and cold. The relationship, doesn't
necessarily want it to end. Feels like this guy's her stability,
right? And he's like, "You're going to you're going to tell me
every single thing you sent to her. You're going to tell me everything
you said, and you're then you're going to text me that you want
to suck my dick, or else I'm never going to trust you. I'm not
going to trust you." Okay?
Like, you have to give me consent right now.
You have to you have to imply you have to tell me that you've
given me consent right now.
It's crazy, right?
You're going to text me that you want to suck my dick or else
I'm not going to trust you. How tall is Mr. Robertson? 6 feet
6 or seven. How tall are you? 5'3.
Okay. Uh,
how much to the best of your knowledge does he weigh? Like 260.
And what is it? Uh, by the way, this is establishing uh in the
like power dynamic wheel of like he was bigger than me, so he's
threatening and I'm small, so I was scared. Right? That's what
she's trying to establish here.
>> Um, and okay. When he had you in that chair in the office,
what was his demeanor towards you? Very angry. Did it cause any
concerns? I was just terrified that she was going to say too
much and he might do something. I don't know. I was just kind
of scared. Okay. And then how after long how long after that
before you confided in someone someone else about the events
that occurred during your relationship?
Him and this other girl went to the anime convention. I asked
my new assistant. She was a friend, a mutual friend of ours to
me.
>> Anyway, that's the So, the text that they're trying
to use and the situation they're trying to use is her basically
getting really scared and this guy
literally forcing her to sit down in this office, call her friend,
and then have her friend explain everything that was told to
her, right? And I I I unless unless somebody wants to contest
this, I'm thinking that he's saying you call her and you start
saying like, "Hey, I forget what I told you. Uh, could you go
through this again?" Dude,
it's insane,
right? To me, it's like totally insane that you do this with
somebody
>> to go with me to the domain that I just
>> He doesn't he Yeah, he literally there's no reaction
to this information. Like this changes nothing for him at all.
that this was a totally contrived thing.
Tech has no career at this, right? Like there there can be no
way. Well, I don't know. I think is Andrew not going to read
the direct examination of Teone
cuz there's only what? There's only like 10 minutes left in this
stream. I don't think he gets to the direct examination of Teone,
right? And that's where the insane happens.
And I wonder if that's
talk to somebody.
>> Just check what he says at the end.
Uh, okay. Hold on. >> I confided in her some of the things
he had, you know, done >> and I told her what do you mean
by the >> That we never had that we would only make him
give me and that he was really worried about it. >> And
me and her have become best friends since then. She's helped
me through a lot. And I know that some assault in your past and
you know you said it was assault and I know the last thing you
want to do is to go into it but can you just tell the court briefly
what happened that so the court understands what the distinction
was in your head first case will for five Canadian says one question
I have techie is also under a PO means mean he can harass make
her feel uncomfortable talking about it doesn't mean she can't
do no it's like I think it's a more of a one-way street
and she gets away with a lot more
>> uh I do think that if she were to make a lot of commentary
in social media, I think that would look really bad if he went
to a judge. I do believe he could file some sort of civil motion.
There would be something he could do to get this in front of
a judge and say, "Why is this screen messed up?" Because we he
has the names and stuff on the screen, so we don't want to show
the screen. Um, he could, I think, tech go to a judge if she
was talking about it a lot, right? I think he could go to a judge
and say, "Hey, she's not like respecting that I'm not allowed
to say anything back and she's [__] with him, right?
She can't interact him or No, that's not true. Matrix order,
Matrix user. She literally can't even say the judge made it clear
last night. Not even Pink could tell Teeone, "Oh, I don't care
about it. Come over." She can't do that. She has no authority
to do that. If she were to do that, Tone would still go to jail
if he goes over to her house or something. She does not have
the authority to rescend the order. Now, if she was constantly
taunting him on social media intentionally or constantly talking
about how he's a or something, I do think eventually the the
provision of this that prevents him from like talking about her
directly would be evaporated, would be like uh it would be gotten
rid of, I think, right? >> So, she's probably not going
to risk >> This is talking about her kind of uh mental
ill her background
here.
Um >> her mental illness,
bro. Did he just do that? mental ill her
talking about her.
Let's just uh let's go back. We went to the bathroom. He pulled
down he told about pulled down my pants and ran me. I cry as
I cried and told him no. This is her talking about her mental
ill. Oh, sorry. Her uh this her this her talking about her mental
ill
are bro.
Bro,
This is talking about her kind of uh mental ill her background
here.
Bruh. Bruh.
You could just tell it's so indicative
Actual mindset. Okay. Holy.
That was crazy. That's a misspeak. You can't really put too much
on it, but that's a crazy misspeak to have in the middle of this.
No, that just I think it actually does tell you that that's he
knows what his goal is. I need to prove that she's mentally ill.
I'm going to make her mentally ill to the internet. That's my
goal. So that everybody will let give Taton a pass.
Um and that was what you determined was a Yes. Okay. And you
followed up with proper authorities and everything for that,
right? Absolutely. And and that was different from than what
Mr. Robertson was doing. Yes. He tried to us out of guilt on
a highway at one point. It was pretty intense. That's not what
Mr. Robinson No, no, not Mr. Robinson. That was the other person.
And that was an extreme event. Extreme events for you. And yes,
all of those are all in the police record because he 5150 for
that. And that is different than the actions that Mr. Robertson
took with you. Yes, that was And your position is I'm sorry.
Let me rephrase that. Mr.
>> It was 100% not a misspeak. He just pretended it was.
[clears throat] He's the guy who's really sensitive about mental
had to engage in behaviors against your behaviors against your
will. Is that right? >> Yes. Okay. And all this occurred
on multiple occasions? Yes. And you still believe that a protective
order is necessary for you and your safety and protection? Yes.
And you're asking the court to grant it today? Yes, please. I
passed the
witness. Mr. Perier, nothing at this time. All right. Brief recess.
All
Let's take a water recess. I'm feeling it, guys.
Are you feeling >> one of the longest streams I've done
in a while? >> Seems like he ends. >> And honestly,
I'm half tempted to
uh let's see. Let me review. Let me let me privately review this
here. How much we got?
Okay, hold on.
I am tempted to break this up into another stream because I'm
like actually really tired right now.
We have a lot >> that that makes some sense. I didn't give
Miz his props entirely for how good he made the Tetone segment.
How long he was reading for. That's really hard that he went
eight hours an 8 hour reading stream. That's actually impressive.
Okay. Got to give Ms. Laurels on that one. That was very impressive.
Legal mindset incapable. Could never. Okay.
Misk went hard.
>> We have a lot to go.
>> I'm tempted. I'm tempted. Tempo is good. We're doing
good,
but we're at like a natural break point here. And I do have a
bus to catch.
People want me to finish.
Take a break. Do it. Okay, stay on. I'm gonna put the I'm gonna
put a a little poll in the chat just to get it here on uh on
on
>> part three is fine. Don't push yourself. It's okay.
Yeah, I think I may I think >> Why does he still look like
it? Because I don't know when he will switch back to documents
or leak more information. Obviously, I'm not I'm literally This
is a filter I have up over my entire browser because I don't
want text showing that has possible information. I think I may
cut it here because I'm feeling it right now. Um, and what I
will promise you guys I will do
>> what I promise you guys I will do >> and I will
send this out after I finish it. So, anybody wants this, we'll
do it after like that.
>> I I cuz I'm feeling it right now. I'm sweating right
now. Um, >> we feeling it. >> Yeah, cuz I'm and I
remember I'm like getting over a sickness too. Um, so thanks
for covering. I'm unsure about Te's innocent after seeing Mujin's
tweet, but after watching your stream and learning more what's
going on, I prefer well Mujin didn't have all the information
and Mujin's also not a lawyer, right? So like he doesn't understand
the legal basis of it and also like he has an audience and you
know I understand people can be like kind of badgered by their
audience, right? So they can
um
>> Oh, I also was not paying attention there for a quick
second. [__] >> Feel like they have to have
a certain take because that's their audience's take. But you
know this is an object. >> Wait, Vin, you said watch till
the end. See what he says at the end. Wait, what did he say at
the end? >> Legal take. Wow, what a read. This is a heck
of a ride. Like high school, the bit I don't miss. This was me.
I'd freak out if I streamer with three terabytes of my hard drive
to deal with. Court discovery. Woof. Much love. Uh, we at least
need all the details. Internet's eating tech alive right now.
No, we're going to get to that. So, we're going to get to that.
So, what I'm saying is we're at a point where we just got through
uh Pikachu. So, then this is a natural break where Pikachu, we
got through Pikachu's testimony, right now we're going to get
other witnesses.
So, we've gotten that part. So, that's why this is a natural
break. It's a good one. Just a bribe for a part three. Yeah.
Take a break. LM part three can wait. Okay, we're doing part
three. I I I'm sorry, guys. I I hate to drag this out, but we
got to do a part three cuz that's it.
>> I did part one stream. The part two never brought up
the leak court docs.
okay. So, the transcript was okay for him to bring up. Okay,
I see what you're saying. Interesting. Yeah, I think I didn't
cover any of the part one on stream at all, so we're all good.
It's part one he privated. I got it. I see
Okay, one second. I need to use the bathroom really quick. Uh,
somebody sent me a new substance tweet. A Hassan [__]
Let's take a quick look. I'm going to let this play. I'm going
to use the bathroom really quick. Okay. Oh, [__]
Well, you're gonna you're gonna see it
Is this the whole thing? This the whole thing. Okay,
one second. I need to restart it. I'll be right back.
God damn, this is pretty funny. Yeah, shout out DG Destiny. I
will have more concurrent viewership than Hassan by 2025. He
said in 2024 when my audience had uh left me behind because of
the Israel stuff. when a big chunk of my audience left.
God damn.
God damn. This is pretty funny. Yeah. Shout out DG Destiny. I
will have more concurrent viewership than Hassan by 2025. said
in 2024 when my audience had uh left me behind because of the
Israel stuff when a big chunk of my Oh, did I leave the potato
graphics on? Oh,
my bad. My bad. My bad.
My bad. Hold on.
We have to watch it a third time because of the potato graphics.
God damn it.
Let me get rid of this stupid thing. Boom. Gone. She gone.
>> Sorry. I'll uh I'll replay it. I'll replay it from the
beginning for you >> God damn. This is pretty funny. >> My
bad. My bad. My bad. >> Shout out DG Destiny. I will have
more concurrent viewership than Hassan by 2025. He said in 2024
when my audience had uh left me behind because >> I don't
think you actually get more information. Whoops. when a big chunk
of my audience left.
Okay. All right.
With that all said, we're done with all of this.
What do we have next on the stream, guys? I'm not totally sure.
I'm not totally sure where we're going next. We got a lot of
time on the stream. Is it time for the Techone schizophrenia
reacted to Dan's logs, too. Oh, apparently, there's lots of stuff
Hassan's reacting to today. Let's take a look. Let's take a look.
Let's take a look. Be the mastermind behind Hassan Piker's YouTube
streaming debut, hitting 140K live concurrent viewers as a plot
to get him to drop Twitch for YouTube. Do you believe him or
is he coping? Now that Assan is banned from Twitch, Destiny debate
collab is going to happen, right? All according to plan, Padavon.
65,000 of those viewers are me. This is good for Bitcoin. He's
going to leave Twitch for YouTube. The goal has to be to keep
him on YouTube. That's a major W. I don't know what you guys
are coping about. There's already a hundred other anti-semites
on YouTube.
Well, thank you, Dan.
Han, if Hassan wasn't so weird about about his bag, Hassan should
just show the the ad revenue from today. Okay, just one YouTube
stream. He should show the ad revenue from one YouTube stream.
I just want to see it, okay? Be like, "Oh, thank you.
Thank you. You bought me You literally bought me a midsize sedan.
Dan Saltman, you literally got me a midsize sedan. Thank you
so much. I appreciate it, dude. Thank you, Dan. He's like Dan's
like, "Oh, I botted his stream.
The level of cope,
the level of cope that we're on. I mean, if he bought my stream,
you know, I feel like that's a terms of service violation for
him
cuz there was a point where we shot up from 60K to like 140K,
but you know,
>> I heard that was totally organic. >> It's been
fairly consistent otherwise on the concurrent viewership front
>> with like a bunch of peaks every now and
And like I said, I would have been happy with like 10,000 uh
with 10,000 viewers.
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
People forming Hassan a lot recently. Okay. It's crazy.
Um Kilo said Hassan could pay for Destiny's lawsuit in a week
of YouTube streams. That's rough, man. That's
He said he's going to donate the ad revenue from that stream.
Oh, that's crazy. Have you seen this? Keith Woods.
No. Well, I saw something from Keith Woods.
Oh, I did see it. Okay. It's not a If we're not going to snark
today, but we'll watch this one thing. I don't think this joke
>> this sounded like this was a joke to me or like it's
referring to something else, right?
>> Cultural bullshism. Hold on. >> What is cultural
bullshism? That's like the first type of like weird
or not I'm sorry stuff. No, during the um I'm not gonna be able
to give you much detail about it, but I think that bullsheism
was like a rise in like artistic movement in um the VHimar Republic.
I
Oh, that's
surely he knows what boism was, right? Surely he knows about
the Bolsheviks. I don't know anything about like
I don't think I don't know anything about u like the fall of
the
the monarchy in Russia but like I understand bullsheism played
a part. There's like um Sar Nicholas and his daughter Anastasia.
I I I I know like some of the things. I've never really looked
at it. Like I I don't know anything beyond just like But how
could you how could you not know that part? Like a little bit
a tiny bit.
You complain about communism a lot.
Isn't this like the the precursor like like basically what caused
the fall and the rise of uh
of like a communist republics
and menix?
Yeah. I don't I don't know. That's that's a joke, right? I feel
like that's a joke. I am Am I crazy? That's got to be a joke.
>> What is cultural bullshism? That's like the first type
of like weird
not I'm sorry.
No, during the party. Um, I'm not going to be able to give you
much detail. >> So, cultural, it looks like cultural bullshism
might be that was a farright anti-semitic term used in the Weimar
Germany and the Germany to denounce modernism, progressive cultural
movements, and secularism as a Marxist plot to destroy traditional
society.
Cultural bullshism, I see, was closely linked to bullshism, conspiracy
theory, which falsely claimed that communists were trying to
undermine Western culture.
Wow. Wow.
This an old clip? I thought it was an old clip. I thought it
was him memeing. I don't know. I don't know, man.
Do we want to kill viewership is the question? Because I do I
do have one thing I want to check out today that you guys are
not going to like. You guys are not going to be fans. Okay.
But there was a Brandon Sanderson stream today that I need to
check out. Hold on. Let me see if it Do I got it here? The live
stream. Wait, where did it go? What
Wait, is it unlisted? Hold on. I got sent it today. There's a
live stream. Brandon Sanderson basically announced that he got
um like a Misborn movie and stuff. Is this Where did this go?
Please tell me he's NOT UNLISTED. YOU SON OF A [__]
He privated the video.
He's an author. He privated the [__] video. Oh god.
Where did the video go?
Um, he's a fantasy author. He's like one He's probably the most
popular fantasy author. He's like the Stephen King of fantasy.
He writes a lot. He writes like a And he gets a ton of fantasy
series out and he's got like a big universe. He talks about like
how you build out like magical systems for fantasy books and
stuff. And he had a whole video today, a whole stream where he
was announcing that he got an Apple deal. I'll just I'll cover
it for two seconds and we'll move on. Apple Brandon Sanderson.
You got like an Apple deal and I believe it's going to be for
both
a Misborn movie, which is one of his series, and a Stormlight
Archive TV series. Apple TV acquires adaptation rights to Brandon
Sanderson's Misborn and Stormlight Archive. Sanderson will reportedly
recreate retain creative control over the adaptations.
Okay.
Yeah, it's the Stormlight Guy.
So,
Apple TV has acquired the rights to Brandon Sanderson's Misborn
and Stormlight Archive books in a massive deal that will see
these two major entries in Sanderson's Cosmir universe adapted
into both TV series and movies. While there's currently no information
available regarding the financial figures involved in the deal,
Id unidentified sources inform the Hollywood Reporter that it
is both lucrative and will reportedly allow Sanderson to retain
an incredible amount of creative control over the adapt associated
adaptations. At present, it's believed that Sanderson will be
able to not just write and produce these those adaptations, but
retain consultation rights and overall creative approval. If
true, that would make this one of the more author friendly adaptation
deals of this size in recent memory. Now,
I can believe that they do this. Sanderson is like very very
open to like a lot of um
like politically correct adaptations. When he was originally
trying to get Misborn adapted this book, he was like he rewrote
a script or he wrote a script. He wrote multiple treatments for
a Hollywood like movie script for this series that involved like
gender swapping a bunch of the characters to try to make it more
woke kind of. And so he's like very open to that. I can see why
they'd let him retain creative control cuz he seems like pretty
open to a lot of stuff.
These adaptations will be Mormon as hell. Why?
Anyway, I was really annoyed when I heard about his Misborn script.
It was actually annoying as hell. It got it just like it it actually
it was annoying. Anyway,
yeah. So,
the the overall series, this will be hugely lucrative. It's an
incredibly popular book series. It's an incredibly popular universe,
and
it's like popcorn stuff, so it's it's just meant to be entertaining.
It's not like super deep. It's not super like incredible pros.
It will benefit a lot from screenwriters taking over and writing,
like rewriting some of the dialogue. Like, all of his weaknesses
are things that Hollywood writers would be good at. And all of
his strengths are things that Hollywood writers suck at, like
writing coherent universes, that have rules, that that um make
sense, that don't like sacrifice major plot points for in the-
moment drama. All the things he's good at are like the things
Hollywood writers suck at. All the things he sucks at are things
Hollywood writers would be good at. So, I think there's a reason
to believe that he would um that this would be good. I'd rather
they did the Steel Hart series. I think that's called The Reckoners.
That's like a child's novel, though. It's like a young adult
novel.
I'll check it out since I don't read. They're okay. Could be
up there with Hunger Games and Dune. It could be really good
depending. It could be really really good.
What's his best series? Um, his best book is a nolla called
uh The Emperor's Soul. That's his best book he's written. It's
like a closed room drama. It's really, really good. His best
series is probably Stormlight Archive.
The best book he's written, the best novel he's written.
Oh, it's tough. It's probably one of the Stormlight novels. War
Breaker is really good. He's got another one. Basically, he wrote
this big universe. Okay, Brandon Sanders has got this huge fantasy
universe called the Cosmir where
a god basically there was a god of this universe. It got shattered
into a bunch of different pieces and the individual a bunch of
mortals took up the pieces and became gods themselves. And then
they pick planets and when they go to those planets they provide
like magic to those planets. The people on those planets the
the animals born on those planets get like magical abilities.
And so these planets are all connected in some way. And each
each of the planets is actually a separate book series that he
writes and it like gives him a bunch of freedom to move around
and he's got this like really deep storyline that's slowly merging
together between all these different planets. It's like kind
of interesting if you like big universes like that that could
melt together. Pretty cool. Sounds like an anime. It is like
It is like fantasy anime. That is what it's like. Yes. Okay.
I got one more Hassan clip and then I think we'll move on to
Teone Schizophrenic re research or something along those lines
because I'm not I'm not totally sure. Oh, also I think Kilo's
going to make a clip here. We'll also check that out in just
a second. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Let me see one
more.
Oh, we did read this. Never mind. We did read this. It was just
this logs thing. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Go to Jake Tapper. Trump is done. Oh, we could check
that out, too.
Uh, hold on, hold on, hold on.
To policy change. Got Hassan banned.
It's just stupid.
I I didn't go deeper into this, but it's just so dumb. Yeah,
we went through it kind of with the Asmin Gold thing where Asoldold
explained it.
We can anti-semite. We read this. We watched this thanks to haters.
>> I will say this. I I never knew it was going to be like
this. I'm going to be honest with you guys. I didn't know it
was going to be like this.
>> I want to give a huge shout out to Ethan
Dan Stalkman, all my haters. I want to give a huge shout out
to the uh Apartheid Defense League and a big shout out to Twitch
as well because I had no
how to do the YouTube live streaming thing at all. I did not
know how to do it at all. I wasn't uh you know prepared for it.
I didn't even monetize this [__] You know what I
mean? And if it wasn't for you guys, if it wasn't for my haters,
I probably would not have brought the [__] Broadcasting
Service to YouTube as well. I probably would not have realized
that there is a massive massive outlet here of Hosanabi heads,
unks in general that
very clearly want me to live stream on here as well.
So, this is making me reconsider if I can build a a membership
structure, a revenue structure here on YouTube.
Who knows?
He's just looking at his dashboard watching that money pile up.
Okay, he's seeing he's going to see that money hit from the ads
for all the viewers he had and he's going to be like, "Oh, oh,
it doesn't even make sense for me to be on on Twitch anymore."
Wait until he sees kick. If you were to come to KEK,